programming throwdown episode 119 the art of vacations take it away patrick well hopefully uh all you listeners aren't going to be thinking you need a vacation after listening to this episode. No, wait, let's just really quick. I want to talk about just like how important this episode is. Like people might see this title and think, wow, Patrick and Jason, they've run out of programming languages or something, but no, this is super, super important. We preempted all of our other show ideas to talk about this, especially with COVID and everything. So, so stay tuned. You're going to learn a lot of good stuff i think a lot of people over i mean when we're recording this now we're at like what 18 18 ish months 17 months of yeah you know kind of like work from home covid all this stuff i think people are really burning out like i i the people i work with the
programming throwdown episode 119 the art of vacations take it away patrick well hopefully uh all you listeners aren't going to be thinking you need a vacation after listening to this episode. No, wait, let's just really quick. I want to talk about just like how important this episode is. Like people might see this title and think, wow, Patrick and Jason, they've run out of programming languages or something, but no, this is super, super important. We preempted all of our other show ideas to talk about this, especially with COVID and everything. So, so stay tuned. You're going to learn a lot of good stuff i think a lot of people over i mean when we're recording this now we're at like what 18 18 ish months 17 months of yeah you know kind of like work from home covid all this stuff i think people are really burning out like i i the people i work with the|||programming throwdown 第 119 期：度假的艺术，帕特里克，请开始吧。好吧，希望听完这期节目后，听众朋友们不会觉得自己需要去度假。不，等等，我们先快速说一下。我想谈谈这期节目有多么重要。人们看到这个标题可能会想，哇，帕特里克和杰森，他们是编程语言用完了还是怎么着，但不是的，这超级超级重要。我们把所有其他的节目构思都搁置一旁来谈论这个话题，特别是鉴于新冠疫情和种种情况。所以，请大家拭目以待。你会学到很多好东西。我觉得很多人在这段时间——我是说，当我们现在录音的时候，我们已经经历了大约 18、18 个月左右、17 个月的……是的，你知道的，居家办公、新冠疫情以及所有这些事情，我觉得人们真的精疲力竭了。就像我，我身边工作的人……
people like i talked i try to encourage them like take time off even if you are just going to stay at home still like get away from your computer. People have gone so long without taking vacations or going anywhere. And even if you're worried about health stuff or whatever, I mean, just the mental... We'll talk about it. We'll talk about it.
people like i talked i try to encourage them like take time off even if you are just going to stay at home still like get away from your computer. People have gone so long without taking vacations or going anywhere. And even if you're worried about health stuff or whatever, I mean, just the mental... We'll talk about it. We'll talk about it.|||就像我交谈过的人一样，我试着鼓励他们：休假吧，哪怕你只是待在家里，也依然要离开你的电脑。人们已经太久没有休假或去任何地方了。而且，即使你担心健康问题或其他什么，我是说，单就心理层面而言……我们会谈到的。我们会谈到的。
I don't want to spoil all of that stuff. But stay tuned. It's really important. Yes, thank you. Don't change the channel. We're showing our age. The intro topic for this episode, I wanted to talk about how cool it is.
I don't want to spoil all of that stuff. But stay tuned. It's really important. Yes, thank you. Don't change the channel. We're showing our age. The intro topic for this episode, I wanted to talk about how cool it is.|||我不想把所有这些内容都剧透。但请拭目以待。这真的很重要。是的，谢谢。别换台。我们这暴露出年龄了。这期节目的开场话题，我想聊聊一件很酷的事。
It's been a somewhat recurring topic on the show, talking about space technology and going to space. And we've covered various topics over the years. That feels weird to say. And I want to say, since our last sort of duo episode, there's been a bunch of really cool news. And I'm not even going to really talk about any of the sort of SpaceX related news. That's like highly covered by other people.
It's been a somewhat recurring topic on the show, talking about space technology and going to space. And we've covered various topics over the years. That feels weird to say. And I want to say, since our last sort of duo episode, there's been a bunch of really cool news. And I'm not even going to really talk about any of the sort of SpaceX related news. That's like highly covered by other people.|||在节目中，谈论太空技术和太空旅行是一个某种程度上反复出现的话题。这些年来，我们涵盖了各种各样的主题。说这话感觉怪怪的。我想说的是，自从我们上一次双人节目以来，已经涌现出一堆非常酷的新闻。我甚至不打算去谈论任何与 SpaceX 相关的新闻。那类新闻已经被其他人大量报道过了。
It's that super exciting. But just like not SpaceX related space news, there's been a lot of cool stuff happen. So Virgin Galactic and had Richard Branson go to, I guess now we have to put air quotes, space and air quotes. There's a whole feud over that. But I mean, like regardless, the fact that they got to where they've been headed
It's that super exciting. But just like not SpaceX related space news, there's been a lot of cool stuff happen. So Virgin Galactic and had Richard Branson go to, I guess now we have to put air quotes, space and air quotes. There's a whole feud over that. But I mean, like regardless, the fact that they got to where they've been headed|||这真是超级令人兴奋。但除了 SpaceX 之外的太空新闻，也有很多酷炫的事情发生。比如维珍银河让理查德·布兰森去了——我想现在我们得打上引号了——“太空”，加上引号。为此还有过一场争论。但我的意思是，无论如何，他们确实到达了他们多年来一直奋斗的目标……
for years. Well, wait, real quick. Was he weightless? Because that's how I define space. Okay, that counts as space to me. I mean, I'm not an expert, but. So there's a difference between like the US and like other countries about where the launch.
for years. Well, wait, real quick. Was he weightless? Because that's how I define space. Okay, that counts as space to me. I mean, I'm not an expert, but. So there's a difference between like the US and like other countries about where the launch.|||……多年之久。等等，说得快一点。他是失重的吗？因为这就是我对太空的定义。好吧，对传送我来说，那就算太空。我的意思是，我不是专家，但是……所以，美国和其他国家在发射地点上是有区别的。
So this wasn't intuitive to me i was explaining it to someone and it's it's kind of weird but earth's atmosphere and i'm gonna get it wrong but earth's atmosphere doesn't just like stop at some point right it's like a gradient and it's dense by the surface and then as you go higher and higher and higher it gets less and less and less less dense right but what where do you put the cutoff point because it's kind of like a probability thing like or a density so the density of atmosphere goes lower and lower but it doesn't just stop at some point yeah that makes sense so you have to sort of arbitrarily kind of define a line where it's like mostly you're out of the atmosphere um but even when you're sort of in orbit and clearly what most people call space you're still experiencing drag and effects of the atmosphere and low earth orbit satellites still experience um actually quite
So this wasn't intuitive to me i was explaining it to someone and it's it's kind of weird but earth's atmosphere and i'm gonna get it wrong but earth's atmosphere doesn't just like stop at some point right it's like a gradient and it's dense by the surface and then as you go higher and higher and higher it gets less and less and less less dense right but what where do you put the cutoff point because it's kind of like a probability thing like or a density so the density of atmosphere goes lower and lower but it doesn't just stop at some point yeah that makes sense so you have to sort of arbitrarily kind of define a line where it's like mostly you're out of the atmosphere um but even when you're sort of in orbit and clearly what most people call space you're still experiencing drag and effects of the atmosphere and low earth orbit satellites still experience um actually quite|||所以这对我来说并不直观，我当时正在向某人解释这件事，这感觉有点奇怪，但地球的大气层——我可能会说错——但地球的大气层并不是在某个点突然停止的，对吧？它就像一个梯度，在靠近地表的地方很稠密，然后当你越来越高、越来越高时，它就会变得越来越不稠密，对吧？但是，你把分界线设在哪里呢？因为这有点像概率问题，或者是密度问题，所以大气的密度越来越低，但它不会在某个点戛然而止。是的，这说得通，所以你必须某种程度上任意定义一条线，在这个线之外，基本上你就已经脱离大气层了。嗯，但即使当你处于轨道上、并且显然处于大多数人所说的太空时，你仍然会经历阻力和大气的影响，近地轨道卫星其实仍然会经历相当……
a bit of drag it's a it's a it's a pretty big problem for them to overcome um so yeah but going weightless is one way to do it but you can go weightless in the what do they call the vomit comet the you know jet passenger plane they stripped all the seats out and then it goes in a parabolic set of like sinusoidal uh up and downs um yeah go weightless in that but you can see the curve of earth from where they went you know it's by some definition space and then shortly after in somewhat of a like we can call it a race um jeff bezos went on the blue origin rocket to to space, to the edge of space, whatever you want to call it. There was even a kerfuffle about whether who and should or shouldn't be considered astronauts. So that all got changed as well.
a bit of drag it's a it's a it's a pretty big problem for them to overcome um so yeah but going weightless is one way to do it but you can go weightless in the what do they call the vomit comet the you know jet passenger plane they stripped all the seats out and then it goes in a parabolic set of like sinusoidal uh up and downs um yeah go weightless in that but you can see the curve of earth from where they went you know it's by some definition space and then shortly after in somewhat of a like we can call it a race um jeff bezos went on the blue origin rocket to to space, to the edge of space, whatever you want to call it. There was even a kerfuffle about whether who and should or shouldn't be considered astronauts. So that all got changed as well.|||……相当大的阻力，这是它们需要克服的一个相当大的问题。嗯，所以是的，进入失重状态是一种方法，但你可以在那种被称为“呕吐彗星”的飞机上体验失重——你知道的，那种拆掉了所有座位的喷气式客机，它会以抛物线或正弦曲线的方式上下起伏。嗯，在那种飞机上也能体验失重，但从他们去过的地方，你能看到地球的弧度，你知道，按某种定义来说，那就是太空。然后不久之后，在一场我们可以称之为竞赛的氛围中，杰夫·贝佐斯乘坐蓝色起源的火箭去了太空、太空边缘，随你怎么称呼它。甚至还引发了一场关于谁应该或不应该被视为宇航员的争论。所以这些也都改变了。
But I think both of those are really cool. There's a separate Virgin company from Virgin Galactic, which is focused on basically space tourism. There's a separate one, Virgin Orbit, which has the ability to actually go into an orbit and put small satellites into orbit. And so they also had another, I think it was their second time, where they were deployed a bunch of these small satellites into orbit. And it's a similar approach. They take a sort of airplane up and then they have a sort of rocket underneath it, but they launch it from a much higher altitude because most of your fuel is spent getting up into speed and through the thickest parts of the atmosphere. And so sort of these three things, just excluding all of the normal NASA stuff and SpaceX stuff are incredibly exciting for me,
But I think both of those are really cool. There's a separate Virgin company from Virgin Galactic, which is focused on basically space tourism. There's a separate one, Virgin Orbit, which has the ability to actually go into an orbit and put small satellites into orbit. And so they also had another, I think it was their second time, where they were deployed a bunch of these small satellites into orbit. And it's a similar approach. They take a sort of airplane up and then they have a sort of rocket underneath it, but they launch it from a much higher altitude because most of your fuel is spent getting up into speed and through the thickest parts of the atmosphere. And so sort of these three things, just excluding all of the normal NASA stuff and SpaceX stuff are incredibly exciting for me,|||但我认为这两者都非常酷。除了维珍银河之外，还有另一家独立的维珍公司，主要专注于太空旅游。还有另一家独立的维珍轨道公司，它有能力真正进入轨道并将小型卫星送入轨道。因此，他们也有过另一次——我想那是他们的第二次——将一堆小型卫星部署到轨道中。这是一个类似的方法。他们用某种飞机把火箭带上去，火箭挂在飞机下方，但他们是从更高的高度发射的，因为你的大部分燃料都花在了加速以及穿过大气层最厚的部分上。因此，这三件事——仅仅排除所有平常的 NASA 和 SpaceX 的事情——对我来说都极其令人兴奋，
at least. I don't know, like I always felt this was, this was going to happen, space tourism, space tourism. If you were, well, I guess you stopped to be a billionaire. But now it's on a trajectory where like, you know, it'll come down in price over time. No idea how low it'll go. But the amount and repeatability of people going to space is going to become much more common in every day. Yeah, it's amazing. I think, so the idea is you have an airplane that's carrying a rocket and the airplane can kind of go, like can climb slowly
at least. I don't know, like I always felt this was, this was going to happen, space tourism, space tourism. If you were, well, I guess you stopped to be a billionaire. But now it's on a trajectory where like, you know, it'll come down in price over time. No idea how low it'll go. But the amount and repeatability of people going to space is going to become much more common in every day. Yeah, it's amazing. I think, so the idea is you have an airplane that's carrying a rocket and the airplane can kind of go, like can climb slowly|||至少对我而言。我不知道，我总觉得这——这将会发生，太空旅游，太空旅游。如果你是……好吧，我想你得是个亿万富翁才行。但现在它的发展轨迹是，你知道的，随着时间推移，它的价格会降下来。不知道会降到多低。但人们进入太空的数量和可重复性将在日常生活中变得更加普遍。是的，这太惊人了。我想，这个构思是这样的：你有一架载着火箭的飞机，这架飞机可以飞行，可以缓慢爬升……
because it's going at this like really flat angle. And then at some point the rocket takes off. Is that how it works? Yeah, that's the Virgin approach. That's not how the Blue Origin Jeff Bezos one does, but that's how the Virgin Orbit and Virgin Galactic work. Yeah, that seems cheaper on its face. It seems like maybe they might be able to get the cost down.
because it's going at this like really flat angle. And then at some point the rocket takes off. Is that how it works? Yeah, that's the Virgin approach. That's not how the Blue Origin Jeff Bezos one does, but that's how the Virgin Orbit and Virgin Galactic work. Yeah, that seems cheaper on its face. It seems like maybe they might be able to get the cost down.|||……因为它以非常平缓的角度飞行。然后在某个时刻，火箭点火起飞。是这样的吗？是的，这就是维珍的方法。蓝色起源杰夫·贝佐斯的那种不是这样的，但这就是维珍轨道和维珍银河的工作方式。是的，表面上看这似乎更便宜。看起来他们也许能够把成本降下来。
You can also reuse the airplane that launched it. I guess it's a big design space and there's many ways to tackle the problems and lots of trade-offs, but it's cool to see different private companies doing it with humans on board to see the, you know, ability to iterate and explore the design space because not everyone's doing it exactly the same. Everyone has a slightly different approach, which means we'll be able to learn much faster. Yeah. It seems like this is really where, like, um think about about engineering sort of hitting mainstream right this is one of those places where like everyone's hearing about these rockets um like not everyone can can watch programming throw down although they should but but not everyone's watching listening to programming throw down but but everyone can especially like you know children
You can also reuse the airplane that launched it. I guess it's a big design space and there's many ways to tackle the problems and lots of trade-offs, but it's cool to see different private companies doing it with humans on board to see the, you know, ability to iterate and explore the design space because not everyone's doing it exactly the same. Everyone has a slightly different approach, which means we'll be able to learn much faster. Yeah. It seems like this is really where, like, um think about about engineering sort of hitting mainstream right this is one of those places where like everyone's hearing about these rockets um like not everyone can can watch programming throw down although they should but but not everyone's watching listening to programming throw down but but everyone can especially like you know children|||你还可以重复使用发射火箭的飞机。我想这是一个巨大的设计空间，有许多方法来解决问题并有很多权衡，但看到不同的私营公司在载人的情况下做到这一点，看到那种迭代和探索设计空间的能力真的很酷，因为并不是每个人的做法都完全一样。每个人的方法都略有不同，这意味着我们能够以更快的速度学习。是的。看起来这确实是……嗯，想想工程技术如何进入主流，这就是其中之一，每个人都在听说这些火箭，嗯，就像不是每个人都能收听 programming throwdown（尽管他们应该听），但并不是每个人都在观看、收听 programming throwdown，但每个人——尤其是，你知道的，孩子们……
can see this like this new space race and get really excited about engineering and tech and all of that. Yeah, I agree. I mean, I think you can observe that it's very likely that the various space launches, even leaving the politics of it aside, but between the Soviet Union, the United States and going to space and both the funding that went into it, probably a big contributor, but even just the like press and coverage on the news that, uh, that got you're right, Jason, I think like it's fundamental for people to see like a very visual representation of what a sometimes more abstract, you know, engineering career can be about. Yeah, that makes sense. That's super cool. I think so. I think I asked you this before, but I don't remember the answer. It's like, when can we go to space for under, let's say, like i think around like a hundred thousand oh that's not far off they're selling tickets i i don't i'd have to look it up i don't have in front of me but i believe that's right about where they're saying and of course like for that it's like a luxury thing like he built this big if you haven't seen
can see this like this new space race and get really excited about engineering and tech and all of that. Yeah, I agree. I mean, I think you can observe that it's very likely that the various space launches, even leaving the politics of it aside, but between the Soviet Union, the United States and going to space and both the funding that went into it, probably a big contributor, but even just the like press and coverage on the news that, uh, that got you're right, Jason, I think like it's fundamental for people to see like a very visual representation of what a sometimes more abstract, you know, engineering career can be about. Yeah, that makes sense. That's super cool. I think so. I think I asked you this before, but I don't remember the answer. It's like, when can we go to space for under, let's say, like i think around like a hundred thousand oh that's not far off they're selling tickets i i don't i'd have to look it up i don't have in front of me but i believe that's right about where they're saying and of course like for that it's like a luxury thing like he built this big if you haven't seen|||……都能看到这场新的太空竞赛，并对工程、技术以及所有这些感到真正兴奋。是的，我同意。我的意思是，你可以观察到，极有可能是各种太空发射——甚至抛开政治不谈——在苏联、美国之间以及进入太空的过程中，投入的资金可能是一个很大的贡献者，但仅仅是新闻界的新闻报道，嗯，这让……你说得对，杰森，我认为对于人们来说，看到有时更抽象的工程职业到底是怎么一回事的极其直观的表现，这是至关重要的。是的，这说得通。这超级酷。我也这么觉得。我想我以前问过你这个，但我不记得答案了。就像是，我们什么时候才能以低于，比如说，大概十万左右的价格去太空？哦，那已经不远了。他们正在卖票。我——我得查一下，我手头没有，但我相信这正是他们所说的价位。当然，对于那个价格，这就像是一件奢侈的事情，比如他建造了这个巨大的——如果你还没看过……
it you should check out like this big space base and you go you can go you know astronaut training and um you know they put you through some some sort of like practice stuff so you kind of what to expect. There's a whole like luxury lounge where like your family can, uh, you know, wait while you do your flight or whatever, right. It's a whole, uh, like a luxury vacation almost, uh, in the middle of the desert, uh, that culminates with you sort of going to space. Wow. Wow. So it's, it's definitely getting there. Yeah. So I, yeah, a hundred thousand down to 20,000 seems like we're on, there's a path where you can see that. The question that I have and people are debating is,
it you should check out like this big space base and you go you can go you know astronaut training and um you know they put you through some some sort of like practice stuff so you kind of what to expect. There's a whole like luxury lounge where like your family can, uh, you know, wait while you do your flight or whatever, right. It's a whole, uh, like a luxury vacation almost, uh, in the middle of the desert, uh, that culminates with you sort of going to space. Wow, Wow. So it's, it's definitely getting there. Yeah. So I, yeah, a hundred thousand down to 20,000 seems like we're on, there's a path where you can see that. The question that I have and people are debating is,|||……你应该去看看这个巨大的太空基地，你可以去参加宇航员训练，嗯，他们会让你经历一些练习之类的东西，好让你对将要发生的事情有所心理准备。还有一个完整的豪华休息室，你的家人可以在那里等待你进行飞行之类的，对吧？这几乎是一个完整的豪华假期，在沙漠的正中央，以你前往太空告终。哇，哇。所以它——它确实在朝那个方向发展。是的，所以——是的，从十万降到两万，看起来我们正在路上，有一条清晰的路径可以看到这一点。我有的以及人们正在争论的问题是：
if this becomes cheaper and cheaper and stronger and better rockets, then what does it mean for point-to-point travel, like going from San Francisco to New York City or going from China to Europe? And can you put passengers on a rocket, fly them up and land them back on the other side in sort of like astonishingly small amounts of time? Can that ever become safe enough? And can it become cheap enough for it to be like a alternative to plane travel? Wow, That'll be wild. Yeah. Can you imagine? That would be totally wild. It's like, uh, you take a family with your flight and at
if this becomes cheaper and cheaper and stronger and better rockets, then what does it mean for point-to-point travel, like going from San Francisco to New York City or going from China to Europe? And can you put passengers on a rocket, fly them up and land them back on the other side in sort of like astonishingly small amounts of time? Can that ever become safe enough? And can it become cheap enough for it to be like a alternative to plane travel? Wow, That's wild. Yeah. Can you imagine? That would be totally wild. It's like, uh, you take a family with your flight and at|||如果这变得越来越便宜、火箭越来越强大、越来越好，那么对于点对点旅行意味着什么，比如从旧金山到纽约市，或者从中国到欧洲？你能不能把乘客送上火箭，把他们送上去，然后在惊人短的时间内将他们降落在地球的另一端？这能变得足够安全吗？它能变得足够便宜，以至于可以成为飞机旅行的替代品吗？哇，那太疯狂了。是的。你能想象吗？那绝对会太疯狂了。这就像，你带着家人一起飞行，然后在……
some point everyone's weightless. So you have to like strap in and then, and then you get back down to earth. That'd be wild. It's like every science fiction book ever. Yes. Yeah, it's true. Cool. Yeah. That's, that's awesome. So how do you follow this stuff? Do you subscribe to a bunch of space blogs or is it? There are some good YouTube channels. So if you sort of go on YouTube, there's a community building, especially with SpaceX doing so much out in the open and iteration. I think it's built up a lot of interest in this. So it's helped to kind of create enough
some point everyone's weightless. So you have to like strap in and then, and then you get back down to earth. That'd be wild. It's like every science fiction book ever. Yes. Yeah, it's true. Cool. Yeah. That's, that's awesome. So how do you follow this stuff? Do you subscribe to a bunch of space blogs or is it? There are some good YouTube channels. So if you sort of go on YouTube, there's a community building, especially with SpaceX doing so much out in the open and iteration. I think it's built up a lot of interest in this. So it's helped to kind of create enough|||……某个时刻每个人都失重了。所以你必须把自己绑好，然后，然后你再回到地球。那太疯狂了。这就像每一本科幻小说里写的一样。是的。是的，确实如此。酷。太棒了。那你平时是怎么关注这些事情的？你订阅了一堆太空博客，还是……有些很好的 YouTube 频道。所以如果你上 YouTube 看看，那里有一个正在建立的社区，特别是随着 SpaceX 在公开场合进行了如此多的活动和迭代。我认为这引发了人们对此的大量兴趣。所以这有助于创造足够的……
money in that in that area to have some sort of full-time coverage on on YouTube so you can check out I don't want to pitch any specific people because then I'll forget others and people will mock me for it but I guess like that's probably how I keep up to date on most of it yeah yeah same here like I mean not not not with space but but the way i catch up on current events is mostly through my youtube subscriptions which is which is a really odd way if you think about it to get the news and so uh yeah it's it's that is really interesting i used to use flipboard but yeah i just i i think what happened is i think like it's it's like a recommender it's an ai fail actually flipboard i don't remember exactly.
money in that in that area to have some sort of full-time coverage on on YouTube so you can check out I don't want to pitch any specific people because then I'll forget others and people will mock me for it but I guess like that's probably how I keep up to date on most of it yeah yeah same here like I mean not not not with space but but the way i catch up on current events is mostly through my youtube subscriptions which is which is a really odd way if you think about it to get the news and so uh yeah it's it's that is really interesting i used to use flipboard but yeah i just i i think what happened is i think like it's it's like a recommender it's an ai fail actually flipboard i don't remember exactly.|||……资金流入该领域，以便在 YouTube 上进行某种全职报道，所以你可以去看看。我不想推荐任何具体的人，因为那样我会忘掉其他人，人们会因此嘲笑我，但我想这大概就是我了解最新动态的方式吧。是的，我也是。我的意思是，虽然不是关于太空的，但我了解时事的方式主要也是通过我的 YouTube 订阅，如果你仔细想想，这获取新闻的方式其实非常奇怪，所以，是的，这真的很有趣。我以前用过 Flipboard，但是，嗯，我只是——我想发生的事情是，我觉得这就像是一个推荐系统，实际上是一个 AI 的败笔。Flipboard，我记不太清了。
Oh, yeah, here's what happened. So, you know, I was looking up some articles about COVID, you know, way back, like more than a year ago. And then, you know, being AI and recommender systems, it just started inundating me with like all these things about COVID and all these people are getting sick and everything. And so it ruined the experience. And so I just stopped using the app. And so, yeah, really, you know, now it's like,
Oh, yeah, here's what happened. So, you know, I was looking up some articles about COVID, you know, way back, like more than a year ago. And then, you know, being AI and recommender systems, it just started inundating me with like all these things about COVID and all these people are getting sick and everything. And so it ruined the experience. And so I just stopped using the app. And so, yeah, really, you know, now it's like,|||哦，对，事情是这样的。你知道的，我当时在查阅一些关于新冠的文章，很久以前，比如一年多前。然后，你知道的，因为是人工智能和推荐系统，它就开始用所有这些关于新冠的事情以及所有这些人如何生病之类的内容来轰炸我。这毁了体验。所以我干脆不用这个应用了。所以，是的，真的，你知道，现在的情况是……
there's not really any place I go to for news other than I just follow some YouTube folks. I have this thing too, yeah. Like sometimes I'll see an article that is evocative and I will not click it because it's like, if I click this, I'm going to get inundated with, you know, whatever it may be. Yeah. Um, you know, COVID conspiracy or celebrity news or whatever you see on it. And every time
there's not really any place I go to for news other than I just follow some YouTube folks. I have this thing too, yeah. Like sometimes I'll see an article that is evocative and I will not click it because it's like, if I click this, I'm going to get inundated with, you know, whatever it may be. Yeah. Um, you know, COVID conspiracy or celebrity news or whatever you see on it. And every time|||……除了关注一些 YouTube 上的博主之外，我真的没有其他地方可以去看新闻了。我也有这种毛病，是的。比如有时我会看到一篇触动心弦的文章，但我不会去点它，因为我觉得，如果我点了这个，我就会被……无论那是什么内容……狂轰滥炸。是的。嗯，你知道的，新冠阴谋论或名人八卦，或者你在上面看到的任何东西。每次……
you're like, ah, I'm bored. No, I'm not going to click it. Yeah. Yeah. You'll pay for it later. Right. Oh man. All right. On to news. My news is a first news is textile brush which is a uh the title is transfer of text aesthetics from a single example so this is a a summary of a research paper i couldn't find any um implementation of it on github yet although i'm sure it'll it'll happen um but it's so cool basically you um can take a picture that has some text on it and you can you can rewrite the text. So if even if it's handwritten, it doesn't matter. So imagine like you take a picture of a billboard somewhere and you could actually just change a text and make the billboard say whatever you want. And it handles like just from that one image, it will learn the style of the font and it will guess what the letters that it doesn't have access to would look like.
you're like, ah, I'm bored. No, I'm not going to click it. Yeah. Yeah. You'll pay for it later. Right. Oh man. All right. On to news. My news is a first news is textile brush which is a uh the title is transfer of text aesthetics from a single example so this is a a summary of a research paper i couldn't find any um implementation of it on github yet although i'm sure it'll it'll happen um but it's so cool basically you um can take a picture that has some text on it and you can you can rewrite the text. So if even if it's handwritten, it doesn't matter. So imagine like you take a picture of a billboard somewhere and you could actually just change a text and make the billboard say whatever you want. And it handles like just from that one image, it will learn the style of the font and it will guess what the letters that it doesn't have access to would look like.|||……你都会想：啊，我好无聊。不，我才不点。是的。是的，你以后会为此付出代价的。没错。噢，天哪。好了。进入新闻环节。我的第一条新闻是 Textile Brush，它的标题是“从单个示例中迁移文本美学（Transfer of Text Aesthetics from a Single Example）”，所以这是一篇研究论文的总结。我在 GitHub 上还没找到它的任何实现，尽管我确信这以后会有的，嗯，但这太酷了。基本上，你可以拍一张带有文字的照片，然后你可以重写这段文字。所以，即使是手写的也没关系。想象一下，你拍下了某处广告牌的照片，你其实可以只更改文本，让广告牌显示你想说任何话。它处理的方式是，仅凭那一张图片，它就会学习字体的风格，并猜测它无法访问的那些字母会是什么样子。
And then it also figures out the pose of the text. And then you can, you know, magic erase that text and then replace it with something else. And I thought that was remarkable. It uses some technology called GANs, which is short for generative adversarial networks. And so basically, I don't think I have too much in the weeds here, but the way it works is you can imagine like if you have the font, right? So imagine like you have the font for something and you go and type a bunch of letters into a Google Doc or something like that. And you take a picture of it.
And then it also figures out the pose of the text. And then you can, you know, magic erase that text and then replace it with something else. And I thought that was remarkable. It uses some technology called GANs, which is short for generative adversarial networks. And so basically, I don't think I have too much in the weeds here, but the way it works is you can imagine like if you have the font, right? So imagine like you have the font for something and you go and type a bunch of letters into a Google Doc or something like that. And you take a picture of it.|||然后它还会弄清楚文本的姿态。然后你可以，你知道的，使用魔术橡皮擦擦掉该文本，然后将其替换为其他内容。我觉得这太卓越了。它使用了一项名为 GANs 的技术，这是生成对抗网络（Generative Adversarial Networks）的简称。所以基本上，我觉得我在这里不需要讲得太过于深入繁琐，但它的工作原理是这样的：你可以想象，如果你拥有某种字体，对吧？所以想象一下，你拥有某种字体的字，然后你去 Google Doc 或类似的东西里输入一堆字母。然后你拍了张照片。
You could, now you have, let's say you have all the letters A through Z and you know what they look like. You could give half of them to a model, a machine learning model, and then ask it to draw the other half. And you know the answer, so you could tell it whether it's doing a good job or not. And so this is called self-supervision.
You could, now you have, let's say you have all the letters A through Z and you know what they look like. You could give half of them to a model, a machine learning model, and then ask it to draw the other half. And you know the answer, so you could tell it whether it's doing a good job or not. And so this is called self-supervision.|||你可以……现在你有了，比方说你拥有从 A 到 Z 的所有字母，并且你知道它们长什么样。你可以把其中一半交给一个模型，一个机器学习模型，然后让它画出另一半。并且你知道答案，所以你可以告诉它它做得好不好。这就叫做自监督（Self-supervision）。
It's when, you know, you know the answer, but the identity of this data is the answer. So, you know, if you hide the letter A and you ask the computer to regenerate it, you know exactly what the answer is, but it's not because you had a person go and label it and say, this is an A, this is a B. It's because you have a generator that can create all of these things and all these different orientations, right? So self-supervision is becoming like really, really hot right now. It's a really interesting area. It's also called contrastive learning. So imagine you have a picture and you delete, you know, a section of the picture and ask the computer to regenerate it. And again, you have the exact answer. You don't have to have a person go in and label it. But it's still like a challenge for the computer to try and
It's when, you know, you know the answer, but the identity of this data is the answer. So, you know, if you hide the letter A and you ask the computer to regenerate it, you know exactly what the answer is, but it's not because you had a person go and label it and say, this is an A, this is a B. It's because you have a generator that can create all of these things and all these different orientations, right? So self-supervision is becoming like really, really hot right now. It's a really interesting area. It's also called contrastive learning. So imagine you have a picture and you delete, you know, a section of the picture and ask the computer to regenerate it. And again, you have the exact answer. You don't have to have a person go in and label it. But it's still like a challenge for the computer to try and|||就是当你知道答案，但这个数据的身份本身就是答案。所以，你知道的，如果你隐藏了字母 A 并让计算机重新生成它，你确切地知道答案是什么，但这并不是因为你让一个人去标记它并说“这是 A，这是 B”。而是因为你拥有一个可以创建所有这些东西以及所有这些不同方向的生成器，对吧？所以自监督现在变得非常非常火热。这是一个非常有趣的领域。它也被称为对比学习（Contrastive learning）。所以想象一下，你有一张图片，然后你删除了图片的一部分，并要求计算机重新生成它。同样，你有确切的答案。你不需要让人工去标记它。但这对于计算机来说仍然是一个挑战，它需要去尝试……
guess like what would have been there. Now, imagine you have a picture of a house and you delete all the pixels of the windows. Right. You're going to have these like really square shaped gaps right where a window should be. And even just as a human, you can look at that and say, oh, yeah, there's probably a window there. Right. And so you're basically training the AI to do that. And because you you've subtracted the answer, you have the answer. You don't have to pay a human to go and label that's why there's no open source people are afraid to to to uh to make this and then unleash pandora's box but but i thought it was a really really interesting research paper it covers it in really good detail and uh you also check it out. It seems like, and I don't know exactly,
guess like what would have been there. Now, imagine you have a picture of a house and you delete all the pixels of the windows. Right. You're going to have these like really square shaped gaps right where a window should be. And even just as a human, you can look at that and say, oh, yeah, there's probably a window there. Right. And so you're basically training the AI to do that. And because you you've subtracted the answer, you have the answer. You don't have to pay a human to go and label that's why there's no open source people are afraid to to to uh to make this and then unleash pandora's box but but i thought it was a really really interesting research paper it covers it in really good detail and uh you also check it out. It seems like, and I don't know exactly,|||……猜测那里原本应该有什么。现在，想象你有一张房子的照片，你删除了窗户的所有像素。没错。在本来应该是窗户的地方，就会出现这种非常方形的空白。甚至作为一个普通人，你看着那个也能说：“哦，是的，那里可能有一扇窗户。”没错。所以你基本上是在训练人工智能这样做。而且因为你减去了答案，你其实是拥有答案的。你不需要付钱找人去打标签——这就是为什么没有开源的原因，人们害怕去制作这个，从而释放潘多拉的魔盒——但我认为这是一篇非常非常有趣的研究论文，它对细节进行了很好的阐述，呃，你也去看看吧。看起来，虽然我不是很确定……
like we covered, what was it called? GPT? Yeah. We covered like a variety of these topics. I feel I'm starting to see like a lot more kind of like applications, like plug and play, not necessarily advancing state of the art alone. I mean, that is also happening.
like we covered, what was it called? GPT? Yeah. We covered like a variety of topics. I feel I'm starting to see like a lot more kind of like applications, like plug and play, not necessarily advancing state of the art alone. I mean, that is also happening.|||……就像我们之前讨论过的，那叫什么来着？GPT？是的。我们涵盖了各种各样的主题。我觉得我开始看到更多类似的应用，比如即插即用的应用，不一定非要单独推进最先进的技术（state of the art）。我的意思是，那方面的发展也在发生。
A lot more of like people doing sort of very human level things, like very visceral things like you're describing with the technology of AI rather than just like a research paper or just some statistics or whatever, but actually kind of doing stuff that humans can sort of interact with and relate to.
A lot more of like people doing sort of very human level things, like very visceral things like you're describing with the technology of AI rather than just like a research paper or just some statistics or whatever, but actually kind of doing stuff that humans can sort of interact with and relate to.|||更多的是人们在做一些非常具有人类层面的事情，比如像你用 AI 技术所描述的那种非常本能、直观的事情，而不仅仅是一篇研究论文或一些统计数据什么的，而是在做一些人类能够与之互动并产生共鸣的事情。
I feel like there's like a groundswell going on there. I don't know where it'll go or where it'll lead. I'm sure you have sort of interact with and relate to. I feel like there's like a groundswell going on there. I don't know where it'll go or where it'll lead. I'm sure you have, you know, sort of thoughts on that, but it definitely seems like some corner got turned. Yeah. I mean, I think that, that, um, yeah, the challenge for AI in the mainstream has been data and compute, right? So like, if you look at Google, Google has so much data and so many computers that they can do things like they can detect, let's say dogs in an image and they could do it really accurately.
I feel like there's like a groundswell going on there. I don't where it'll go or where it'll lead. I'm sure you have sort of interact with and relate to. I feel like there's like a groundswell going on there. I don't know where it'll go or where it'll lead. I'm sure you have, you know, sort of thoughts on that, but it definitely seems like some corner got turned. Yeah. I mean, I think that, that, um, yeah, the challenge for AI in the mainstream has been data and compute, right? So like, if you look at Google, Google has so much data and so many computers that they can do things like they can detect, let's say dogs in an image and they could do it really accurately.|||我觉得那里正在酝酿着一股强烈的浪潮。我不知道它会走向何方，也不知道它会引领我们去向何处。我确信你对……能够与之互动并产生共鸣。我觉得那里正在酝酿着一股强烈的浪潮。我不知道它会走向何方，也不知道它会引领我们去向何处。我确信你对此（你知道的）有一些看法，但它绝对看起来像是转过了某个拐角。是的。我的意思是，我认为，嗯，是的，人工智能在主流领域面临的挑战一直是数据和算力，对吧？所以，如果你看看谷歌，谷歌拥有如此多的数据和如此多的计算机，以至于他们可以做这样的事情：比如他们可以检测图像中的狗，并且能够非常准确地做到这一点。
For you to do that, you would need to have a person go in and say, this picture has a dog, this picture doesn't have a dog. And you'd have to do that millions of times and you have to pay that person. And so just to make, this picture doesn't have a dog, and you'd have to do that millions of times and you have to pay that person. And so, you know, just to make, if you didn't have any data, you have to create all the data sets yourself. But even like, imagine taking photos of millions of dogs, right? Like you're talking about, like it would take you hundreds of thousands
For you to do that, you would need to have a person go in and say, this picture has a dog, this picture doesn't have a dog. And you'd have to do that millions of times and you have to pay that person. And so just to make, this picture doesn't have a dog, and you'd have to do that millions of times and you have to pay that person. And so, you know, just to make, if you didn't have any data, you have to create all the data sets yourself. But even like, imagine taking photos of millions of dogs, right? Like you're talking about, like it would take you hundreds of thousands|||为了让你做到这一点，你需要派一个人进去说：“这张照片有狗，这张照片没有狗。”你必须重复数百万次，而且你必须付钱给那个人。所以仅仅为了让……这张照片没有狗，你必须重复数百万次，而且你必须付钱给那个人。所以，你知道的，为了制作……如果你没有任何数据，你必须自己创建所有的数据集。但即使像——想象一下拍下数百万只狗的照片，对吧？就像你所说的那样，这会花费你几十万美元……
of dollars to build a dog detector if you didn't, if you had to, you know, curate the data. And so that has held most people back. I mean, the big companies are obviously doing it. They have the millions of dollars, but for, for most small and medium businesses, they just, it's just not an option. Right. And so, but then, yeah, if you look at people, right, like you could, with some very simple training, you could start to recognize different breeds of dogs. Like maybe you do already. I mean, I personally know nothing about dogs, but I feel like if I was to spend a few days, I could learn the most common breeds and I could start telling dogs apart, right? So as people, we could do it. And so the question is, how do we build that sort of base of intelligence where then someone doesn't need to spend so much money to do something? And so the question is, how do we build that sort of base of intelligence where then someone doesn't need to spend so much money to do something? And so self-supervised learning seems to be the answer to that question. I mean, the jury is still out, but that's where it's kind of leaning towards, which is super exciting because it's going to open a whole bunch of opportunities. And so, yeah, it turns out that playing this game of
of dollars to build a dog detector if you didn't, if you had to, you know, curate the data. And so that has held most people back. I mean, the big companies are obviously doing it. They have the millions of dollars, but for, for most small and medium businesses, they just, it's just not an option. Right. And so, but then, yeah, if you look at people, right, like you could, with some very simple training, you could start to recognize different breeds of dogs. Like maybe you do already. I mean, I personally know nothing about dogs, but I feel like if I was to spend a few days, I could learn the most common breeds and I could start telling dogs apart, right? So as people, we could do it. And so the question is, how do we build that sort of base of intelligence where then someone doesn't need to spend so much money to do something? And so the question is, how do we build that sort of base of intelligence where then someone doesn't need to spend so much money to do something? And so self-supervised learning seems to be the answer to that question. I mean, the jury is still out, but that's where it's kind of leaning towards, which is super exciting because it's going to open a whole bunch of opportunities. And so, yeah, it turns out that playing this game of|||……来构建一个狗检测器，如果你不这样做，如果你必须（你知道的）精心策划和整理数据的话。所以这阻碍了大多数人。我的意思是，大公司显然在这样做，他们有数百万美元的资金，但对于大多数中小企业来说，这根本不是一个选项。没错。所以，但是随后，是的，如果你看看人类，对吧？就像你通过一些非常简单的训练，就可以开始识别不同品种的狗。就像你可能已经能做到了。我的意思是，我个人对狗一无所知，但我觉得如果我花几天时间，我可以学会最常见的品种，并且我能开始分辨不同的狗，对吧？所以作为人类，我们能做到这一点。那么问题来了，我们如何建立那种基础智能，从而让人们不需要花那么多钱去做某事？那么问题来了，我们如何建立那种基础智能，从而让人们不需要花那么多钱去做某事？所以自监督学习似乎是这个问题的答案。我的意思是，目前还没有最终定论，但事情正朝着这个方向倾斜，这超级令人兴奋，因为它将开启一大堆机会。所以，是的，事实证明，玩这种“猜测缺失部分”的游戏……
guessing the missing thing ends up building a foundation. And then on top of that, you can do other AI things without needing so much data. And so you're going to see more and more of this where there'll be some enormous machine learning model that Google has trained on all of their images. And you can start with that and then do your task on top of it. I think that it's called transfer learning. I think that is really starting to take off now. That's fascinating. Yeah, we'll see where it goes.
guessing the missing thing ends up building a foundation. And then on top of that, you can do other AI things without needing so much data. And so you're going to see more and more of this where there'll be some enormous machine learning model that Google has trained on all of their images. And you can start with that and then do your task on top of it. I think that it's called transfer learning. I think that is really starting to take off now. That's fascinating. Yeah, we'll see where it goes.|||……最终会建立起一个基础。然后在此基础之上，你可以做其他的人工智能事情，而不需要那么多数据。因此，你会看到越来越多的这种情况：谷歌在他们的所有图像上训练了一个庞大的机器学习模型，你可以从这个模型开始，然后在它的基础之上完成你的任务。我想这被称为迁移学习（Transfer learning）。我认为这现在真的开始腾飞了。太迷人了。是的，我们拭目以待它会走向何方。
I mean, the whole appeal of deep learning was that transfer. The whole premise of deep learning was that transfer learning doesn't work right people used to do people used to do um svd like singular value decomposition right which or pca or one of these things so they would take an image and they would crush it down to like 30 numbers right and then they would do machine learning on the 30 numbers and and actually pat, we did this when we were... Yeah, but I was just going to say, I remember doing this with you. Yeah. I mean, we actually built these things that would take images and crush them down to like either smaller images or sets of numbers. And then we would do machine learning in that small space.
I mean, the whole appeal of deep learning was that transfer. The whole premise of deep learning was that transfer learning doesn't work right people used to do people used to do um svd like singular value decomposition right which or pca or one of these things so they would take an image and they would crush it down to like 30 numbers right and then they would do machine learning on the 30 numbers and and actually pat, we did this when we were... Yeah, but I was just going to say, I remember doing this with you. Yeah. I mean, we actually built these things that would take images and crush them down to like either smaller images or sets of numbers. And then we would do machine learning in that small space.|||我的意思是，深度学习的全部吸引力就在于这种迁移。深度学习的整个前提是迁移 learning 行不通，对吧？以前人们做……以前人们做……嗯，SVD，比如奇异值分解（singular value decomposition），对吧？或者是 PCA 或其中之一。所以他们会拿一张图片，然后把它压缩成大约 30 个数字，对吧？然后他们对这 30 个数字进行机器学习。而且事实上，帕特，我们在……时做过这个。是的，但我正要说，我记得曾和你一起做过这个。是的。我的意思是，我们确实构建过这些东西，它们会获取图像并将其压缩成更小的图像或一组数字。然后我们在那个小空间里进行机器学习。
And then deep learning killed all of that because it was just so much better. And it could just go from raw pixels to the answer without this in-between layer that is doing something that's not aware of the problem, right? And so now you're going back to that, where now you're going back to like, yeah, Google gives you this model that they trained using self-supervision, not knowing anything about your task. The real difference is now you can update the model. So imagine if you started with doing SVD, but then if the problem, if two images are very similar,
And then deep learning killed all of that because it was just so much better. And it could just go from raw pixels to the answer without this in-between layer that is doing something that's not aware of the problem, right? And so now you're going back to that, where now you're going back to like, yeah, Google gives you this model that they trained using self-supervision, not knowing anything about your task. The real difference is now you can update the model. So imagine if you started with doing SVD, but then if the problem, if two images are very similar,|||然后深度学习扼杀了所有这些，因为它实在是好太多了。它可以直接从原始像素得出答案，而不需要这个介于中间的、做着对问题一无所知的事情的中间层，对吧？所以现在你们又回到了这一点，现在你们回到了像——是的，谷歌给你提供这个他们使用自监督训练的模型，它对你的任务一无所知。真正的区别在于，现在你可以更新模型了。所以想象一下，如果你从做 SVD 开始，但如果问题是——如果两张图片非常相似……
but they're actually different labels, like one's a dog and one's a cat, but they're just similar, the SVD will put them in the same space, but then your problem will pull them apart again. And so as long as your problem can kind of modify the SVD, you're good. That's a nice thing about doing the dimensionality reduction with neural nets is that you can always change the way that they're reducing later as you introduce like a real problem and so that's that's the gamble yeah go ahead no i was gonna say is that so the idea there is that somehow like when google trains this model on everything right it doesn't end up recording everything but it builds some the words are going to get picky i guess but it builds some understanding about how to tell what is or isn't in a picture and like tell pictures apart and like structure of images. So then when
but they're actually different labels, like one's a dog and one's a cat, but they're just similar, the SVD will put them in the same space, but then your problem will pull them apart again. And so as long as your problem can kind of modify the SVD, you're good. That's a nice thing about doing the dimensionality reduction with neural nets is that you can always change the way that they're reducing later as you introduce like a real problem and so that's that's the gamble yeah go ahead no i was gonna say is that so the idea there is that somehow like when google trains this model on everything right it doesn't end up recording everything but it builds some the words are going to get picky i guess but it builds some understanding about how to tell what is or isn't in a picture and like tell pictures apart and like structure of images. So then when|||……但实际上它们的标签不同，比如一个是狗，一个是猫，但它们只是很相似，SVD 会把它们放在同一个空间里，但随后你的问题会把它们再次拉开。因此，只要你的问题能够某种程度上修改 SVD，就可以了。用神经网络进行降维的好处在于，当引入一个真正的问题时，你以后总是可以改变它们降维的方式，所以这就是——这就是那个赌注。是的，请继续。不，我正要说的是，那里的想法是，不知何故，当谷歌在所有东西上训练这个模型时，对吧？它最终并没有记录所有东西，但它建立了一些——用词可能会变得挑剔，我猜——但它建立了一些关于如何分辨图片中有什么或没有什么的理解，以及如何区分图片和图片的结构。所以然后当……
you go to train it with a much smaller dataset custom to yours, like you're only sort of changing how it interprets that structural understanding of the images. Yeah, pretty much. And the other thing is there's an assumption here that, for example, symmetry is important. And so almost any image processing thing you're going to train is going to take advantage of that. counter example is if you had just random noise and the goal was to predict like the number of white pixels, like so you have, so you have a random binary image that's just generated with random numbers and you want to predict how many pixels are white. That is going to be really, really hard to transfer learn, right? Because there's no symmetry, there's, there's, there's nothing real there. And so it's going to be worse actually than if you had just trained it from scratch. Right. But that is like, people don't
you go to train it with a much smaller dataset custom to yours, like you're only sort of changing how it interprets that structural understanding of the images. Yeah, pretty much. And the other thing is there's an assumption here that, for example, symmetry is important. And so almost any image processing thing you're going to train is going to take advantage of that. counter example is if you had just random noise and the goal was to predict like the number of white pixels, like so you have, so you have a random binary image that's just generated with random numbers and you want to predict how many pixels are white. That is going to be really, really hard to transfer learn, right? Because there's no symmetry, there's, there's, there's nothing real there. And so it's going to be worse actually than if you had just trained it from scratch. Right. But that is like, people don't|||……你去用针对你的定制的小得多的数据集来训练它时，就像你只是在某种程度上改变了它如何解释对图像的这种结构理解。是的，差不多是这样。另一件事是，这里有一个假设，例如，对称性是很重要的。因此，你将要训练的几乎任何图像处理东西都会利用这一点。反例是，如果你只有随机噪声，而目标是预测白色像素的数量——比如你有，比如你有一个仅用随机数字生成的随机二值图像，并且你想预测有多少像素是白色的。那将非常非常难以进行迁移学习，对吧？因为没有对称性，没有，没有，那里没有什么真实的东西。所以它实际上会比你从头开始训练它还要糟糕。没错。但这就像是，人们不会……
do that. Right. Like that's not useful. And so when you look at like the class of useful things you can do with computer vision, almost all of them have like need those same building blocks. And so that's, that's why it becomes useful man i think uh we should definitely have some more episodes to hear you talk about this this is actually uh very interesting actually yeah so spoiler alert we're actually we have a guest who's an expert on exactly this on embeddings and transfer learning who i'm trying to schedule so so we actually we are going to spend a whole episode on it. So hopefully, actually, it's not confirmed yet.
do that. Right. Like that's not useful. And so when you look at like the class of useful things you can do with computer vision, almost all of them have like need those same building blocks. And so that's, that's why it becomes useful man i think uh we should definitely have some more episodes to hear you talk about this this is actually uh very interesting actually yeah so spoiler alert we're actually we have a guest who's an expert on exactly this on embeddings and transfer learning who i'm trying to schedule so so we actually we are going to spend a whole episode on it. So hopefully, actually, it's not confirmed yet.|||……这样做。没错。这没用。因此，当你看到可以用计算机视觉做的一类有用事情时，几乎所有这些事情都——需要那些相同的构建块。所以这就是——这就是它变得有用的原因。天哪，我觉得，嗯，我们绝对应该多做几期节目来听你谈论这个，这其实——真的非常有趣。是的，剧透一下，我们实际上——我们有一位正是这方面的专家的嘉宾，专门研究嵌入（embeddings）和迁移学习，我正在努力敲定他的档期，所以——所以我们实际上会用整整一期节目来专门聊这个。所以希望，事实上，这还没有最后确认。
I'm still trying to get them on the show. But yeah, that's coming up. So stay tuned. I know something about embedded software, but I'm pretty sure that's not what you mean by embedded. But speaking of embedded software, I'll segue into my next topic, which has to do with integer overflows. So a little bit of a setup. There's a
I'm still trying to get them on the show. But yeah, that's coming up. So stay tuned. I know something about embedded software, but I'm pretty sure that's not what you mean by embedded. But speaking of embedded software, I'll segue into my next topic, which has to do with integer overflows. So a little bit of a setup. There's a|||我还在努力邀请他们上节目。但是的，这就要来了。所以敬请期待。我对嵌入式软件略知一二，但我很确定这并不是你所说的嵌入。不过说到嵌入式软件，我将顺理成章地过渡到我的下一个话题，这与整数溢出（integer overflows）有关。所以先做点铺垫。有一个……
guy named Warren Buffett, who's like pretty famous investor. He runs a company called Berkshire Hathaway. And they do a variety of things. They actually own a lot of like household names. So let's see, like, I think they own like Geico insurance. They own like Helzberg diamonds. Oh, I didn't know they owned anything. I thought they just bought their own stocks or something. So they do a little bit of everything. So they do own some companies and continue to own them. I think Seas Candy as well. Oh, interesting. There's like a variety. You can go, there's a list somewhere of all the like virtual Hathaway companies where they sort of find companies, they sort of help them, you know, replace the
guy named Warren Buffett, who's like pretty famous investor. He runs a company called Berkshire Hathaway. And they do a variety of things. They actually own a lot of like household names. So let's see, like, I think they own like Geico insurance. They own like Helzberg diamonds. Oh, I didn't know they owned anything. I thought they just bought their own stocks or something. So they do a little bit of everything. So they do own some companies and continue to own them. I think Seas Candy as well. Oh, interesting. There's like a variety. You can go, there's a list somewhere of all the like virtual Hathaway companies where they sort of find companies, they sort of help them, you6|||……叫沃伦·巴菲特的家伙，他是个相当著名的投资者。他经营着一家名为伯克希尔·哈撒韦（Berkshire Hathaway）的公司。他们做各种各样的事情。他们实际上拥有许多家喻户晓的品牌。让我们看看，比如，我想他们拥有像 Geico 保险。他们拥有像赫尔斯伯格钻石（Helzberg Diamonds）。哦，我不知道他们还拥有其他东西。我还以为他们只是买自己的股票什么的。所以他们什么都涉猎一点。因此他们确实拥有一些公司并继续持有它们。我想还有 See's Candies（喜诗糖果）。哦，很有趣。有各种各样的。你可以去看看，某个地方有一份伯克希尔·哈撒韦公司的名单，他们在那里寻找公司，某种程度上帮助它们……
management. And then they have like a, oh gosh, a synergy between the companies. Like one might throw out a lot of extra cash. One, you may need a lot of cash on hand, like in an insurance case, in case you have to do payouts. So there's like reasons to have some of these companies together, which is one of the things he sort of like, I don't want to say like pioneered, like got right. But they also do temporarily like buy parts of Apple and then sell it back without taking a controlling interest.
replacement of the management. And then they have like a, oh gosh, a synergy between the companies. Like one might throw out a lot of extra cash. One, you may need a lot of cash on hand, like in an insurance case, in case you have to do payouts. So there's like reasons to have some of these companies together, which is one of the things he sort of like, I don't want to say like pioneered, like got right. But they also do temporarily like buy parts of Apple and then sell it back without taking a controlling interest.|||……更换管理层。然后他们就像是——哦天哪，公司之间产生了一种协同效应。比如一家可能会吐出大量多余的现金。另一家，你可能需要手头有大量现金，就像在保险案例中那样，以防你必须进行赔付。所以把其中一些公司组合在一起是有原因的——这是他某种程度上——我不想说是什么开创了先河，而是说做对了的事情之一。但他们也会临时性地买入一部分苹果公司的股票，然后又将其卖回，而不获得控股权。
And there he has, so there's a thing when your stock price starts to get really high, it becomes really hard for people to buy a share. Recently things, a lot of stock brokerages have allowed you to buy fractional shares, which we won't talk about like how that implies like with voting rights, it gets into the whole thing. But you can now buy fractional shares, but you didn't used to be able to buy a part of a share.
And there he has, so there's a thing when your stock price starts to get really high, it becomes really hard for people to buy a share. Recently things, a lot of stock brokerages have allowed you to buy fractional shares, which we won't talk about like how that implies like with voting rights, it gets into the whole thing. But you can now buy fractional shares, but you didn't used to be able to buy a part of a share.|||在这里他有这样一个情况：当你的股价开始变得非常高时，人们要想买一股就会变得非常困难。最近，许多股票经纪公司允许你购买碎股（fractional shares）——我们不讨论这如何暗示着投票权之类的事情，那会扯到整个别的话题上去。但你现在可以买碎股了，而以前你是无法购买股票的一部分的。
So as companies' stock price rose, it became so expensive that for an individual retail customer, they couldn't buy shares, or if they wanted to buy, like, I want to buy $1,000, but your stock is $750. There's like this $250 leftover, you would have bought of the company that you can't. So a lot of companies do stock splits to reduce their stock price and bring it down lower. And there's a variety of reasons why that may or may not be a good idea. But Warren Buffett has, like very famously said, he doesn't want to split his stock. He's not going to split his stock. There is actually two classes of stock, Berkshire A and Berkshire B. Berkshire Hathaway B actually trades at a lower price because it takes multiple of those shares to equal one of the Berkshire A shares. But Berkshire A has famously never split. But it's continued to be a very successful company for many decades.
As companies' stock price rose, it became so expensive that for an individual retail customer, they couldn't buy shares, or if they wanted to buy, like, I want to buy $1,000, but your stock is $750. There's like this $250 leftover, you would have bought of the company that you can't. So a lot of companies do stock splits to reduce their stock price and bring it down lower. And there's a variety of reasons why that may or may not be a good idea. But Warren Buffett has, like very famously said, he doesn't want to split his stock. He's not going to split his stock. There is actually two classes of stock, Berkshire A and Berkshire B. Berkshire Hathaway B actually trades at a lower price because it takes multiple of those shares to equal one of the Berkshire A shares. But Berkshire A has famously never split. But it's continued to be a very successful company for many decades.|||随着公司股价上涨，它变得如此昂贵，以至于对于个人散户客户来说，他们买不起股票，或者如果他们想买，比如，我想买 1000 美元的股票，但你的股票是 750 美元。就会剩下这 250 美元，你本可以用它购买公司的股份却买不了。因此，许多公司通过股票分割（stock splits）来降低股价，使其降得更低。关于这是否是一个好主意，有各种各样的原因。但沃伦·巴菲特非常著名地表示过，他不想拆股。他不会拆分他的股票。实际上有两种类别的股票，伯克希尔 A 类股（Berkshire A）和伯克希尔 B 类股（Berkshire B）。伯克希尔·哈撒韦 B 类股的交易价格实际上较低，因为需要多股 B 类股才能等于一股伯克希尔 A 类股。但伯克希尔 A 类股闻名遐迩地从未进行过拆股。然而几十年来，它一直是一家非常成功的公司。
And it turns out that some of the exchanges, in this case, Berkshire Hathaway stock is traded on the New York Stock Exchange, and they didn't have this issue. But NASDAQ Stock Exchange publishes feeds of data that people use for, for instance, like the Yahoo or Google Finance, when you go there and you look up a stock price, they use the NASDAQ feed of prices in order to show it to you, even for things which aren't listed on NASDAQ. That's a whole other topic. And what happened is Berkshire Hathaway stock got to a price where they had to actually delist it for a while, some of the things that they were listing. And the reason why is not that the stock price reached, what is it? So they were storing it as a 32-bit value in this NASDAQ
And it turns out that some of the exchanges, in this case, Berkshire Hathaway stock is traded on the New York Stock Exchange, and they didn't have this issue. But NASDAQ Stock Exchange publishes feeds of data that people use for, for instance, like the Yahoo or Google Finance, when you go there and you look up a stock price, they use the NASDAQ feed of prices in order to show it to you, even for things which aren't listed on NASDAQ. That's a whole other topic. And what happened is Berkshire Hathaway stock got to a price where they had to actually delist it for a while, some of the things that they were listing. And the reason why is not that the stock price reached, what is it? So they were storing it as a 32-bit value in this NASDAQ|||事实证明，一些交易所——在这种情况下，伯克希尔·哈撒韦的股票在纽约证券交易所交易，他们没有这个问题。但纳斯达克证券交易所发布的数据源（feeds）被人们用于，例如雅虎或谷歌财经，当你去那里查询股票价格时，他们使用纳斯达克的报价数据源来向你展示，即使对于未在纳斯达克上市的东西也是如此。那是另一个完全不同的话题。发生的事情是，伯克希尔·哈撒韦的股票价格达到了一个高度，以至于他们实际上不得不将其暂时退市（delist），取消了他们正在挂牌的一些东西。原因并不是股票价格达到了——是多少来着？所以他们在这个纳斯达克数据源中将其存储为 32 位值……
feed to keep it nice and compact. You don't normally use floats or doubles when you're doing finance stuff because you can get sort of, well of well it's a whole other topic but how you get numerical stability you get sort of uh not exact representations of some fractions so instead what they do is they use a you call it like a fixed point thing they represent hundreds of cents in 32 bits so you have only what 4.3 billion so the stock price did not reach 4.3 billion. So the stock price did not reach 4.3 billion per share, but it did reach $435,000, which if you represent times a hundred, so a penny would be what? Times 10 times, or times a hundred times a hundred. So times 10,000 equals really close to 4.3 billion. So they had to preemptively delist the stock from, I guess it was like the price of the last sale and a couple of the other kinds of feeds that they have, not
feed to keep it nice and compact. You don't normally use floats or doubles when you're doing finance stuff because you can get sort of, well of well it's a whole other topic but how you get numerical stability you get sort of uh not exact representations of some fractions so instead what they do is they use a you call it like a fixed point thing they represent hundreds of cents in 32 bits so you have only what 4.3 billion so the stock price did not reach 4.3 billion. So the stock price did not reach 4.3 billion per share, but it did reach $435,000, which if you represent times a hundred, so a penny would be what? Times 10 times, or times a hundred times a hundred. So times 10,000 equals really close to 4.3 billion. So they had to preemptively delist the stock from, I guess it was like the price of the last sale and a couple of the other kinds of feeds that they have, not|||……以保持其精简紧凑。你在做金融相关事情时通常不会使用浮点数（floats）或双精度数（doubles），因为你会得到某种——好吧，这也是一个完全不同的话题，但关于如何获得数值稳定性，你会得到某些分数的不精确表示。所以他们转而做的是，他们使用一种你称之为定点数（fixed point）的东西，他们在 32 位中表示美分的百分之一（即百分之一美元），所以你只有大约——什么？43 亿，所以股票价格并没有达到 43 亿。因此，每股股价并没有达到 43 亿美元，但它确实达到了 435,000 美元，如果将其表示为乘以一百——所以一分钱会是什么？乘以 10 倍，或者乘以一百倍的一百。所以乘以 10,000 非常接近 43 亿。因此，他们不得不将该股票从——我猜是最后一次交易价格以及他们的其他几种数据源中——进行抢先退市，而不是……
the daily closing, which is what kind of most people see, but this sort of intraday, like what is the last price that the stock has been exchanged at? They had to delist it from there because what would have happened is once it reached the 32-bit representational max is it would have wrapped around and it would have looked like the stock price was trading for fractions of a penny and so that would have been awesome it would have been a really good deal bye bye there was some pressure given which i don't know how you apply pressure to a very very rich person like that but so they kind of asked warren bovin like, hey, could you just split it? Like maybe, but he wouldn't. So what they ended up having to do is preemptively delist from some of these feeds. So actually, there are some crazy pictures
the daily closing, which is what kind of most people see, but this sort of intraday, like what is the last price that the stock has been exchanged at? They had to delist it from there because what would have happened is once it reached the 32-bit representational max is it would have wrapped around and it would have looked like the stock price was trading for fractions of a penny and so that would have been awesome it would have been a really good deal bye bye there was some pressure given which i don't know how you apply pressure to a very very rich person like that but so they kind of hawk warren bovin like, hey, could you just split it? Like maybe, but he wouldn't. So what they ended up having to do is preemptively delist from some of these feeds. So actually, there are some crazy pictures|||……每日收盘价（大多数人看到的正是这个），而是这种日内交易价，比如股票最后一次交易的价格是什么？他们不得不将其从那里退市，因为将会发生的是，一旦它达到 32 位表示的最大值，它就会回绕（wrapped around），并且看起来股票价格好像是以一分钱的一小部分在交易，所以那将会太棒了，那会是一笔非常划算的交易，拜拜。有人施加了压力——我不知道你该如何向这样一个非常非常富有的人施加压力——所以他们有点像鹰派一样追着沃伦·巴菲特问：嘿，你能把它拆分一下吗？也许可以吧，但他不肯。所以他们最终不得不做的是，从其中一些数据源中抢先退市。所以实际上，你在互联网上可以找到一些疯狂的图片……
that you can find on the internet of like the Google stock ticker or like the Yahoo one where it like kind of glitches out when it started hovering around that price. And even today, I assume it's still related. If you go to Google and you search for Berkshire A, BRK.A, which is the one we've been talking about, the daily, the sort of intraday trade price is just blank. It won't show it to you. So if you click on like the month view or the year view where it's showing only the price at the end of the day, you can see that. But the graph for what's happening within a day is just blank, presumably because it's still not available because they're at such a high price. Wow, that is wild. It actually looks very similar to the Theranos stock graph,
that you can find on the internet of like the Google stock ticker or like the Yahoo one where it like kind of glitches out when it started hovering around that price. And even today, I assume it's still related. If you go to Google and you search for Berkshire A, BRK.A, which is the one we've been talking about, the daily, the sort of intraday trade price is just blank. It won't show it to you. So if you click on like the month view or the year view where it's showing only the price at the end of the day, you can see that. But the graph for what's happening within a day is just blank, presumably because it's still not available because they're at such a high price. Wow, that is wild. It actually looks very similar to the Theranos stock graph,|||……比如谷歌股票代码或雅虎股票代码的截图，当价格开始在该价位附近徘徊时，它就会出现某种故障。甚至在今天，我猜这仍然与之相关。如果你去谷歌搜索伯克希尔 A 类股（BRK.A）——也就是我们一直在讨论的那只股票——日内交易价格那一栏是一片空白。它不会向你展示。因此，如果你点击月视图或年视图（只显示每天结束时的价格），你可以看到。但显示一天内发生情况的图表却是一片空白，据推测是因为由于股价太高，该数据仍然不可用。哇，这太疯狂了。它实际上看起来非常类似于 Theranos 的股票走势图，
but for different reasons. It's not the same. If someone offers you shares of Theranos it's probably not a good idea to buy unless you really know something that no one else does yeah oh my gosh oh man yeah that is wild so are they is are they still in a deadlock or is is somebody gonna budge there i think i have to recode all of their stuff you know i have no idea i don't know how you do an update to like switch a bit width from 32 bits to 64 bits and this is like a feed that gets published and you know paid for by like probably i don't even like hundreds thousands tens of thousands of different institutions like yeah i guess you make a v2 of it and then you make that one 64 bits and then you tell people you know they need they need to move to the V2 of the API.
but for different reasons. It's not the same. If someone offers you shares of Theranos it's probably not a good idea to buy unless you really know something that no one else does yeah oh my gosh oh man yeah that is wild so are they is are they still in a deadlock or is is somebody gonna budge there i think i have to recode all of their stuff you know i have no idea i don't how you do an update to like switch a bit width from 32 bits to 64 bits and this is like a feed that gets published and you know paid for by like probably i don't even like hundreds thousands tens of thousands of different institutions like yeah i guess you make a v2 of it and then you make that one 64 bits and then you tell people you know they need they need to move to the V2 of the API.|||但原因不同。情况不一样。如果有人向你提供 Theranos 的股票，买入可能不是个好主意，除非你真的知道别人不知道的事情。哦，天哪，天哪，是的，这太疯狂了。所以他们——他们还在僵持不下，还是会有人在那里妥协让步？我想我得重新编写他们所有的代码，你知道的，我毫无头绪，我不知道你该如何进行更新，比如将位宽从 32 位切换到 64 位，而这是一个发布的数据源，你知道的，付费购买它的可能有——我甚至都不敢想——成百上千甚至数万家不同的机构。所以，是的，我猜你得制作一个它的 V2 版本，然后把那个版本设为 64 位，接着你告诉人们，你知道的，他们需要迁移到该 API 的 V2 版本。
I mean, that's a huge problem. I remember when YouTube views hit 4 billion on a video and that was a massive, massive problem. And yeah, that's wild. Yeah, I mean, it's so interesting that on one hand, it's like, yeah, maybe this person should, you know, just let them split. But on the other hand, it's like, yeah, maybe this person should, you know, just let them split. But on the other hand, it's like, well, maybe they should fix their old code.
我的意思是，那是个大问题。我记得当 YouTube 上某个视频的浏览量达到 40 亿时，那成了一个非常、非常大的问题。而且，是的，这太疯狂了。是的，我的意思是，很有意思的是，一方面，你会觉得，是的，也许这个人应该，你知道的，就让他们拆分吧。但另一方面，你会觉得，嗯，也许他们应该修复旧代码。
I mean, yeah, it seems like kind of a silly reason to split. Like somebody assumed your stock price would never get this high and it did. So like, do you mind making it lower? I mean, it's probably great coverage, too, you know. I don't think I don't think Warren Buffett and Berkshire Hathaway need more coverage, but yeah, potentially. OK, yeah yeah, potentially. Okay. Yeah. Fair enough. Yeah. Everyone wants to see it break the stock market, so they'll just buy it for that reason. Yeah. I guess I should mention the region he doesn't want to split. I left that unsaid was that he actually doesn't want the churn that
我的意思是，是的，这看起来像是一个很愚蠢的拆分理由。就像有人认为你的股价永远不会涨这么高，结果它真的涨了。所以，就像，你介意把它弄低一点吗？我的意思是，这可能也是很好的报道，你知道的。我不认为沃伦·巴菲特和伯克希尔·哈撒韦公司需要更多的报道，但是的，有可能。好吧，是的，有可能。好吧。好吧，有道理。是的。每个人都想看到它打破股市纪录，所以他们就会为了这个原因买入它。是的。我想我应该提一下他不想拆分的理由。我没说出口的是，他其实并不想经历零售投资者带来的
comes with retail investors. So people who buy you know, buy it at a lower price, kind of move in and out a lot more and it gets a lot more churn. He doesn't want, he wants people buying and sort of holding the stock and investing and letting it go up over time. Um, so that, that's sort of his, his theory there. That makes sense. I could see that. Yeah. Yeah. It's really interesting. Yeah. I have a whole, I mean, yeah, we won't go into the segue,
客户流失。所以那些买入，你知道的，在较低价格买入的人，往往会频繁进出，这就导致了大量的客户流失。他不想这样，他希望人们买入并长期持有股票、投资，让它随着时间推移而上涨。嗯，所以，这就是他的一些理论。这说得通。我能理解。是的。是的，这真的很有趣。是的。我有一整套，我的意思是，是的，我们不会展开这个题外话，
but the whole thing about public companies and effectively random people telling your company what to do is so strange to me. But that would take a whole hour to talk about. I'll jump into mine. It's LineageOS. I've gotten so many emails from folks about either the Pine phone or the, I think it's called Librem phone. So many people are interested in this, um, you know, open source phones and, and totally, uh, free and open source software, uh, you know, driven phones and open hardware phones. I looked into it. I thought about maybe doing, maybe we'll still do a show on it, but I looked into it and I found that a lot of them are either very expensive.
但关于公众公司和基本上随机的人告诉你的公司该怎么做整件事，对我来说太奇怪了。但这需要整整一个小时来谈论。我切入我的话题吧。它是 LineageOS。我收到了很多听众发来的电子邮件，谈到 Pine 手机或者，我想它叫 Librem 手机。很多人对此感兴趣，嗯，你知道的，开源手机以及完全、自由和开源的软件，嗯，你知道的，驱动的手机和开源硬件手机。我研究了一下。我考虑过也许做一期节目，也许我们还是会做一期关于它的节目，但我研究后发现它们中的很多要么非常昂贵。
Like, I think the Librem five is like $2,000 or something like that. Or it just seems like a real homebrew thing that maybe you couldn't really rely on if there was an emergency or something. And so this actually, in my opinion, seems like the way to go is, I wouldn't say specifically LineageOS, there might be a better one, but it seems like, you know, getting an existing phone and just, and just rewriting the, the OS and you're relying on the quality control of the hardware manufacturer seems like, you know, a safer option, especially if it's Android and you're putting another Android, you know, fork of Android on there. And so LineageOS is one of these where, you know, they have a list of approved devices that they on there. And so Lidige OS is one of these where, you know, they have a list of approved devices that they've tested. And so you can go and buy like, say a
比如，我认为 Librem 5 售价约 2,000 美元或类似的价格。或者它看起来就像一个真正的自制玩艺儿，如果遇到紧急情况或其他情况，你可能无法真正依赖它。所以实际上，在我看来，这才是正确的出路，我不是说特指 LineageOS，可能还有更好的选择，但看起来，你知道的，买一部现成的手机，然后，然后重写操作系统，并且你依赖硬件制造商的质量控制，这似乎是一个，你知道的，更安全的选项，特别是如果是安卓系统，并且你在上面安装另一个安卓，你知道的，安卓分支。所以 LineageOS 就是其中之一，你知道的，他们有一个他们测试过的认证设备列表。因此，你可以去买一部，比如说
Pixel 3. I don't know if Pixel 3 is on there now, but you could buy, let's say a Pixel 3, and they'll show you step-by-step how to install this open source OS. And then you get, you know, everything now is totally open source. There's not really any surprises or anything like that. And, and they have their own app store and, and everything like that. And so this, you know, um, I have to really dive into this, but I know that folks who listen to the show are super interested in this and I wanted to, to give my take on it based on the research I've done so far and, and actually throw it back at, at folks out there. So if you've emailed us about Pine phone and these things, you know, take a look, take a look at this
Pixel 3。我不知道 Pixel 3 现在是不是在上面，但你可以买，比方说一部 Pixel 3，他们会一步一步地教你如何安装这个开源操作系统。然后你就会得到，你知道的，现在所有的东西都是完全开源的。真的没有任何惊喜或诸如此类的东西。而且，他们有自己的应用商店，以及诸如此类的东西。所以这个，你知道的，嗯，我必须深入研究这个，但我知道听这个节目的听众对这个超级感兴趣，我想根据我到目前为止所做的研究给出我的看法，并且，实际上把这个抛给，嗯，外面的听众。所以如果你给我们发过关于 Pine 手机和这些东西的邮件，你知道的，看一看，看一看这个，
and then, and then, uh, feel free to opine and we can have a, have a discussion on it. This sounds like something you've looked into, Patrick, have you looked into any of this like tiny phone or any of this? Yeah. You know, I i have some but it's kind of the same i i love like playing with embedded stuff but i guess i treat it as like not reliable things like my phone i'm kind of picky about i just for various reasons i just want a phone that i know is going to work that i know like if i pick it up and call a number it's going to like ring if i text someone yeah you know i don't i don't know the few times my phone doesn't work or crashes, we had this experience.
然后，然后，嗯，欢迎发表高见，我们可以就此进行讨论。听起来你好像研究过这个，帕特里克，你研究过任何像这种微型手机或类似的东西吗？是的。你知道的，我有过一些，但有点像，我喜欢玩嵌入式的东西，但我猜我把它当作不太可靠的东西来对待，比如我的手机，我有点挑剔，出于各种原因，我只想要一部我知道能用的手机，我知道如果我拿起来拨个号，它就会响，如果我给某人发短信，是的，你知道的，我不知道，我的手机不工作或崩溃的那几次，我们有过这种经历。
Actually, we went on vacation a couple of weeks ago and we had flown somewhere. And when we landed, neither my wife nor I's phone would work. And it was incredibly hard to call the Uber without like our phones being on the, specifically the LTE wouldn't work. And so we like tried like turning on airplane mode, turning it off.
实际上，几周前我们去度假了，我们坐飞机去了某个地方。当我们降落时，我和我妻子的手机都无法使用了。而且在手机无法使用的情况下叫 Uber 简直难于登天，特别是 LTE 无法工作。所以我们尝试了，比如开启飞行模式，再关闭。
We eventually were able to go on like the airport wifi and like call the Uber. But then when we walked out to like meet them, like the phone stopped working and they weren't where they said they were. And I had to go back inside. It was a huge mess. And then it actually turned out to be a little embarrassing. And when we got to the hotel, we're like, hey, does this, you know, cell provider not work? They're like, no, no, it should work. Have you tried restarting your phone?
我们最终得以连接到机场的 wifi 并叫了 Uber。但当我们走出去准备见他们时，手机又停止工作了，而且他们不在他们说的地方。我不得不走回里面。那真是一团糟。然后结果证明还有点尴尬。当我们到达酒店时，我们问，嘿，这个，你知道的，蜂窝网络提供商不能用吗？他们说，不，不，应该能用。你试过重启手机吗？
Like, no, that doesn't do anything. Restarted our phones, sure enough, like it came back. And I was like, no, really? Yes. Wow. And the same thing happened when we flew back here. It wouldn't work until we rebooted our phones. And it's just like that little glitch.
就像，不，那没用。重启了手机，果然，就像它又恢复了。我就想，不会吧？是的。哇。当我们飞回这里时也发生了同样的事情。在重启手机之前它一直无法工作。就像那个小故障一样。
And it just like it was miserable trying to like get that Uber and like, yeah. So anyways, phone's not working. And like the monitor is just like, we've come completely to depend on them. So no, I've not spent a ton of time in this particular pulling of the thread. Yeah, I might. Yeah, I agree with you.
就像尝试叫 Uber 简直痛苦万分，就像，是的。所以无论如何，手机无法正常工作。就像显示器一样，我们完全依赖它们。所以不，我并没有在深入研究这个特定问题上花太多时间。是的，我可能会。是的，我同意你的看法。
I also have the same fear of things like, I guess it would have to support the Play Store, right? Because like if you couldn't, you know, I'm sure Uber is not on this lineage OS store. I mean, almost 100% sure. So yeah, if you can't run one of the major app stores, then it seems like that's a non-starter or you have to carry two phones.
我也同样担心诸如，我想它必须支持 Play Store，对吧？因为如果你不能，你知道的，我确信 Uber 不在这个 Lineage OS 商店里。我的意思是，几乎 100% 确定。所以，是的，如果你不能运行其中一个主流的应用商店，那似乎就是一个行不通的起点，或者你必须带两部手机。
But yeah, I think there's the idea of going to open store. I mean, you know, I don't know about you, but I run Linux at home. And so, you know, that's become just part of my daily life. So I feel like it might just be a matter of time. Actually, I guess you're running at least Unix. So yeah, that, there we go let's um that's what that's what windows runs on top no i'm just oh my god actually wait is free bsd i'm totally gonna get so much hate for this yeah yeah moving to the next topic yeah let's just move on my mine is actually a book i guess i could use this for the book of the show but there is a website i'm following about building your own interpreter and sort of walking through scratch i saw my perpetual like i have many things like this that i want to work um by a guy robert i think you say his name
但是，是的，我认为有转向开源商店的想法。我的意思是，你知道的，你怎么样我不知道，我在家里运行 Linux，所以，你知道的，那已经成为我日常生活的一部分。所以我觉得这可能只是时间问题。实际上，我想你至少在运行 Unix。所以，好吧，那就这样吧，让我们，嗯，这就是 Windows 运行的基础，不，我只是，哦天哪，其实等等，是 FreeBSD，我绝对会因此招来超多骂声，好吧，好吧，进入下一个话题，好吧，我们继续吧，我实际上是一本书，我想我可以把它用作本期节目的书，但我关注了一个关于构建你自己的解释器并从头开始逐步讲解的网站，我看到了我的永恒——我有许多这样我想做的事情——由一个名叫罗伯特的人，我想他是这个名字
nystrom and he previously wrote i think it was like game design patterns which i felt like was a really good like approach to some design patterns under the guise of talking about it as a game because people understand games lots of people want to build games and i think he came from the the video game industry but he's been writing these blog posts you can still get them for free and like the complete sort of like book in serialized form but he decided to make an actual print book uh in a pdf and the reason why is one calling out that, like, hey, there's this cool resource, you can check out about learning to write your own interpreters. But also, like, you know, it's still in this day and age, like, it's somewhat of an accomplishment to be like,
尼斯特姆 (Nystrom)，他以前写过，我想是像《游戏设计模式》这样的书，我觉得这是一种非常好的方法，以探讨游戏为幌子来讲解一些设计模式，因为人们懂游戏，很多人想做游戏，我想他来自视频游戏行业，但他一直在写这些博客文章，你仍然可以免费获得它们，就像连载形式的完整书籍一样，但他决定制作一本真正的印刷版书籍，嗯，做成 PDF，原因之一是呼吁大家注意，嘿，这里有一个很酷的资源，你可以查看关于学习编写你自己的解释器的内容。但同时，你知道的，在当今时代，这仍然算是一种成就，就像是，
I took what was blog posts, and like, did the proper sort of formatting and got it into a book shape. And just the sort of like, how in some ways, even in my head, like it kind of gets to something a blog never does, like a finality. Like he has the book. That means it's kind of like done. So even if I don't go read the book and I go read it on his website,
我把曾经的博客文章，进行了适当的排版，并做成了一本书的形状。这就像某种程度上，甚至在我的脑海里，它达到了一种博客永远无法做到的事情——一种确定性。就像他有了这本书。这意味着它有点像完成了。所以即使我不去读这本书，而是去他的网站上读，
there's some like indication that like it's been made. It's a real thing. It contains valuable information. It's just this interesting observation that one, like shout out to him, like that's super cool. And definitely go check out the material. The bits that I've gone through are very well done. And I really liked it. But just this other thing that this sort of pointing out that it's kind of interesting that it took sort of like formatting and producing the book, even though I'll probably not read the book itself to kind of make it into this,
也有某种迹象表明它已经被做出来了。这是一件真实的事情。它包含有价值的信息。这只是一个有趣的观察，一方面，向他致敬，这太酷了。绝对要去看看这些材料。我读过的部分做得非常好。我真的很喜欢它。但还有另一件事，即指出这一点很有趣，即它需要对书籍进行排版和制作，尽管我可能不会去读这本书本身，但却能把它变成这样一种，
like it's done. Yeah, that's awesome. It's a great way to, I think, you know, I've seen similar patterns followed by like XKCD and other folks where they get a print book. And I think, I think it's a great idea. You know, just, it's a good like coffee table thing. All right. I think it's time for book of the show. Book of the show. My book of the show is how to lead in product management. And so I'll tell you what inspired me to get this book. I, I, uh, a friend of mine or a colleague of mine who, uh, like the product manager for, um, our team is actually really knowledgeable about engineering, has sort of like an engineering background. And it's just so easy to talk to this person. I mean, they get it. Pardon me. They get it. They understand, you know, the challenges and, you know, they don't know as much about machine learning and AI as somebody, an engineer on the team, but they know a lot and it really helped them a lot. And it's also just kind of cool. It's like, oh, this person
它完成了。是的，太棒了。我认为这是一个好方法，你知道的，我见过像 XKCD 和其他人遵循的类似模式，他们出一本印刷版书籍。而且我认为，我认为这是一个好主意。你知道的，它只是一件很好的咖啡桌摆件。好了，我想是时候进入本期推荐书籍环节了。本期推荐书籍。我推荐的书是《如何领导产品管理》(How to Lead in Product Management)。所以我来告诉你是什么启发我买这本书的。我，我，嗯，我的一个朋友或同事，嗯，就像我们团队的产品经理，实际上对工程学非常了解，某种程度上具有工程背景。而且和这个人交谈非常容易。我的意思是，他们懂。对不起。他们懂。他们理解，你知道的，这些挑战，而且，你知道的，他们对机器学习和人工智能的了解可能不如团队中的某个工程师那么多，但他们了解很多，这真的对他们帮助很大。而且这也挺酷的。就像是，哦，这个人
gets it. They're one of us, right? And so I thought, oh, maybe I'll do this in the other direction because I talked to a lot of product managers at work and I probably sound like a total dummy when it comes to building a product or advancing a product. So I thought I would get this book and learn more about that field. It's been really interesting. I think that there's something really nice about learning a new area because you learn a lot very quickly, right? Like you're not hit with this law of marginality, right? And yeah, I mean, just a couple of things I pulled out of the book so far is there's this idea of having sort of shared goals and how to kind of get people aligned around the same goal. It talks about, you know, what's the difference between a vision, which is sort of like a three-year plan, and then a, like a milestone, which is a six-month plan, and then a
懂。他们是我们自己人，对吧？所以我想，哦，也许我可以反过来这样做，因为我在工作中和很多产品经理交谈，在构建产品或推进产品方面，我听起来可能像个彻头彻尾的笨蛋。所以我想我可以买这本书，更多地了解那个领域。这真的很有趣。我认为学习一个新的领域有一些非常美妙的地方，因为你可以非常快地学到很多东西，对吧？就像你不会受到这种边际效应递减规律的打击，对吧？是的，我的意思是，到目前为止我从书中提取的几点是，有一个关于拥有某种共享目标以及如何让人们围绕同一个目标保持一致的想法。它谈到了，你知道的，愿景（这有点像三年计划）和一个，比如里程碑（六个月计划）之间的区别，然后是一个
sprint, which is like a two-week, one to two-week plan. And sort of how you, like, other than just the timeline, like, what are the actual implications of having those different timelines and how do you handle them differently? One thing I thought was really interesting is it talks about, because the book is How to Lead in Product Management, it talks about how to have a coherent vision and still give autonomy to individual product managers. And so I thought that was really interesting, right? Because people think about the stereotypical Steve Jobs, like throwing the phone across the room and like upset because like the font, like the letter T isn't shaped the right way. Like these are like the stories that are so outlandish that they become famous, right? But the reality is, you know, all of these good product leaders
冲刺（两周，一到两周的计划）。以及你如何，除了时间表之外，这些不同时间表实际的含义是什么，以及你如何以不同的方式处理它们。我认为非常有趣的一点是，它谈到了，因为这本书是《如何领导产品管理》，它谈到了如何保持一个连贯的愿景，同时仍然赋予个别产品经理自主权。所以我觉得这非常有趣，对吧？因为人们会想到刻板印象中的史蒂夫·乔布斯，把手机扔过房间，因为字体，比如字母 T 的形状不对而心烦意乱。就像这些故事是如此离奇，以至于它们变得出名，对吧？但现实是，你知道的，所有这些优秀的产品领导者
were extremely good about creating a system of autonomy and doing that and balancing that against their own, you know, personal views and everything. So the book covers a lot of this stuff and I found it fascinating. It's not a long book. It's only a, I think, five and a half hour lesson on Audible, so if you're interested in that, in that discipline, definitely pick it up. Yeah. That's, that's a great tip. I liked your observation too, about like, what do you want to call it? Cross training, like yeah. Running stuff outside of your, uh, specific job description. Uh, my book is Holy sister by Mark Lawrence. This is a of the Book of the Ancestor trilogy.
在创建自主权系统以及在他们自己的（你知道的）个人观点和其他方面之间进行平衡方面都非常出色。所以这本书涵盖了很多这样的内容，我觉得它很吸引人。这不是一本厚书。在 Audible 上只有大约五个半小时的课程，所以如果你对那个学科感兴趣，一定要买一本。是的。那是，那是一个很好的建议。我也喜欢你的观察，关于，你想怎么称呼它？交叉培训，就像，是的。在你的特定职位描述之外做一些事情。我的图书是马克·劳伦斯的《圣女》(Holy sister)。这是《祖母绿三部曲》(Book of the Ancestor) 的其中一本。
And this is the third book. We talked on the show a while ago. I actually finished this book a while ago about the first in the series, Red Sister. Then there's Gray Sister and this is Holy Sister. And this book is about, I always struggle with this. I guess I could just read the back cover, but since it's the third book, it's spoilers
这是第三本书。我们前不久在节目中谈过。我实际上不久前刚看完这本书关于系列的第一本《红姐妹》(Red Sister)。然后是《灰姐妹》(Grey Sister)，这就是《圣女》。这本书是关于，我总是为此纠结。我想我可以直接读封底，但既然是第三本，如果你没看过第一本，
if you haven't read the first book. But basically there's, you know, it's a fantasy book with sort of a magic system. This book does, you know, I think pretty good. It's always hard to wrap up a series, like to finish the trilogy. People can complain, you know, it wasn't expected. You just, you end up either, you know,
就会被剧透。但基本上有，你知道的，这是一部带有某种魔法系统的奇幻书。这本书，你知道的，我认为相当不错。结束一个系列总是很难，比如完成三部曲。人们会抱怨，你知道的，这是意料之外的。你最终会要么，你知道的，
leaving stuff out or not finishing it in three and going to four or five six and sort of getting stuck like uh some authors i think have have sort of fallen prey to um but this trilogy is done at the third book and it sort of comes to a conclusion but what i liked about it is there's like a magic system that that's pretty different and there's some stuff about the world building and, um, it doesn't go slow. Like the book, each book is sort of like interesting and engaging and really moves stuff forward. But then there is like kind of a slow burn, like world building. There's other stuff that you're sort of aware of,
遗漏一些东西，或者没有在三本书中结束，而是写到第四、五、六本，并陷入困境，就像一些作者，我想，已经沦为这种现象的牺牲品；但这个三部曲在第三本完结了，并且算是得出了一个结论。但我喜欢的是，有一个非常不同的魔法系统，还有一些关于世界构建的东西，而且，它节奏不慢。这本书，每一本都让人觉得有趣、引人入胜，并且真正推动了情节的发展。但随后又有一种缓慢发酵的感觉，比如世界构建。还有其他一些你隐约意识到，
but you don't quite know that you're figuring out. And just that sort of like a sense of discovery that I get by reading some fiction, science fiction books, specifically, you know, or fantasy, I just really enjoy being able to like go on that, that sort of journey. I guess some movies can do that too. And sometimes it's like a plot twist. But I don't like ones that are just like, oh, there's this came out of right field and wasn't really hinted at. Or I guess out of left field, out of left field and wasn't really hinted at. I like ones where the it was there if you knew where to look, right?
但又不太清楚你在搞懂的东西。以及我通过阅读一些小说、科幻小说，特别是（你知道的）或奇幻小说所获得的这种探索感，我真的很喜欢能够去经历那种旅程。我想有些电影也能做到这一点。有时就像一个情节反转。但我不喜欢那种纯粹是，哦，这凭空出现而且之前根本没有暗示的。或者我想是意料之外、毫无征兆的。我喜欢那种如果你知道去哪里找，它其实就一直在那里的情节，对吧？
Like there were sort of nods and hints to it all along. And if you were to rewatch it or like think back, you're like, oh, almost like, how did I miss this? Or, oh, wow, that's really cool. That's why that thing that was left unsaid. Those are some of my favorite kind of experiences. And I thought this book did a good job sort of capturing that in this trilogy.
就像一路上都有那种点头示意和暗示。如果你回看或者回想起来，你会觉得，哦，几乎就像，我怎么会错过这个？或者，哦，哇，这真的很酷。这就是为什么那个没说出口的事情会是那样。这些是我最喜欢的一些体验。我觉得这本书很好地捕捉到了三部曲中的这种感觉。
And Mark Lawrence has some other series as well, but I'm not going to talk about them because they may be a future book of his shows. Nice. We were at a mall the other day, like not a mall, but a plaza and there was a warhammer 40k store oh really a games workshop store oh yeah yeah i think that's right yeah and um and there's a bunch of books and uh i was there with with uh my older son and he was he's checking out
而且马克·劳伦斯还有其他一些系列，但我不会谈论它们，因为它们可能是他节目的未来书籍。太棒了。我们前几天在一个购物中心，就像不是购物中心，而是一个广场，那里有一家战锤 40k 的店，哦真的吗，一家 Games Workshop 的店，哦是的，是的，我想是这样，并且，那里有很多书，嗯，我在那里和我大儿子在一起，他在看
the books and um do you have any experience with those like is is like maybe like 40k universe like yeah right you're not talking about the game manuals you're talking about just the fiction works right right like do you think that would be a good uh or like maybe a better question is what what would you think would be a good book for like kids who are getting into sci-fi you know that's that's really interesting so ender's game is like a really classic oh yeah i've read that yep like first first thing but i actually think this this one's a little tough like people especially kids like you want them to be it's not a chore like if you tell them to read a book you're automatically
这些书，嗯，你对这些有什么经验吗？比如，像 40k 宇宙是否，是的，对吧，你说的不是游戏手册，你说的只是小说作品，对吧，对吧？你觉得这会是一个好，或者说更好的问题是，你觉得对于开始接触科幻小说的孩子们来说，什么会是一本好书呢？你知道的，这真的很有趣——安德的游戏 (Ender's Game) 就像是一个非常经典的，哦，是的，我读过，没错，就像是第一，第一部。但我实际上认为这本有点难——人们，尤其是孩子，你希望他们觉得阅读不是一件苦差事。如果你告诉他们去读一本书，你自动地
kind of like it's not good it it's something they need to like you know maybe provide like a selection or like some guidance into like a certain you know uh curated set that like hey like which of these seems interesting to you oh yeah like like motivating kids to read until like some point um is more about like having them choose stuff that they were interested in reading because even if you, yeah, that book ended up being dumb. My kids have read some of those. Like, wow, that book was not very good. But like if they were interested,
就会让人觉得，这不好。这需要他们去，你知道的，也许提供一种选择或者对某种，你知道的，精选集的指导，比如，嘿，这些里面哪个对你来说似乎很有趣？哦，是的，就像——在某个时间点之前激励孩子们去阅读，更多的是让他们选择他们有兴趣阅读的东西，因为即使他们，是的，那本书最后证明很烂。我的孩子们读过其中的一些。就像，哇，那本书不是很好。但如果他们感兴趣，
they feel the sense of accomplishment of finding something they wanted to do and then doing it. Yeah, right. I mean, I don't know. No, I don't know anything specifically about the Warhammer 40K universe. But whether good or bad. But yeah, I mean, I think if it's something they're really into, then they're much more likely to coast through. If there's like boring parts of the book or whatever, then if you sort of like recommend
他们会有一种成就感，因为他们找到了自己想做的事情然后去做了。是的，对吧。我的意思是，我不知道。不，我对战锤 40k 宇宙没有任何具体的了解。但无论是好是坏。但是的，我的意思是，如果那是他们真正投入的事情，那么他们更有可能轻松度过。如果书中有些无聊的部分或者其他什么，那么如果你推荐了一本书，
a book and they get to some part and then they just like it's a chore to do the reading. Yeah, yeah, totally makes sense. Cool. Yeah. And if you want to read any of these books, or if you want your kids to read any of these books or if you want your kids to read any of these books, they could do it on Audible or I guess listen to any of these books. I'm still actually, I've gotten back into Audible and I'm not commuting anymore because of work from home. But what I've started doing is listening to audio books in the evening or I've been going on walks. The nice thing is I go on a walk and the path that I take,
而他们读到某一部分，然后觉得阅读成了一件苦差事。是的，完全说得通。酷。是的。如果你想读这些书中的任何一本，或者如果你想让你的孩子读这些书中的任何一本，他们可以在 Audible 上读，或者我猜是听这些书中的任何一本。我其实仍然，我又开始用 Audible 了，而且因为居家办公，我不再通勤了。但我开始做的是在晚上听有声书，或者我一直在散步。好处是我去散步时，我走的那条路，
I actually lose cell phone reception because I go through this kind of valley that doesn't have good coverage. And the nice thing about Audible is I've downloaded the book and so I can listen. It doesn't cut out or anything like that versus if I do anything streaming and I get halfway through my walk loaded the book. And so I can listen, you know, it doesn't cut out or anything like that. Um,
我实际上会失去手机信号，因为我穿过了一个信号覆盖不好的山谷。而 Audible 的好处是我已经下载了书，所以我可以听。它不会中断或诸如此类，而如果我进行任何流媒体播放，当我走到散步的一半时，下载了书。所以我可以听，你知道的，它不会中断或诸如此类。
versus if I do anything streaming and I get halfway through my walk and it's, it's just sputtering or sounding like a robot. So, so yeah, I've been actually getting back into audible for that reason. And if you want to do that, um, you can go to audible trial.com slash programming throwdown. We'll have a link in the, uh, in the show the show notes and uh that gives you a free month and also helps to show it as well if you already have an audible subscription and you don't need another one you can uh follow us on patreon patreon.com slash programming throwdown and uh you can go on there we have super fast uh download sites there's a special site for patreon subscribers um who uh special rss seed for those folks and uh yeah you should check that out i think it's time for tool
相比之下，如果我进行任何流媒体播放，当我走到散步的一半时，它就会结结巴巴或者听起来像个机器人。所以，是的，我其实因为这个原因重新开始使用 Audible。如果你想这样做，你可以访问 audibletrial.com 斜杠 programming throwdown。我们会在节目文稿中提供一个链接，这会给你一个月的免费试用，如果你已经有了 Audible 订阅并且不需要另一个，如果你已经有一个 Audible 订阅并且不需要另一个，你可以关注我们的 Patreon patreon.com 斜杠 programming throwdown，你可以上去，我们在那里有超快的下载网站，为 Patreon 订阅者提供一个特殊的网站，为这些人提供一个特殊的 rss 种子，是的，你应该去看看。我想是时候介绍本期推荐工具了。我本期推荐的工具是《7 billion humans》，这是一款电子游戏。这些年来，很多人都建议把编程作为电子游戏，你知道的，就像你在游戏中编写计算机程序的电子游戏——《Human Resource Machine》对，等一下，那是什？对不起，那是那些游戏之一，我想那是《Human Resources》，哦，是的，所以这实际上是那款游戏的续集。哦，好吧，哦，《Human Resource Machine》，没错。所以，应听众的要求，我玩过很多这样的游戏。而我唯一喜欢的只有《Human Resource Machine》。就像所有其他游戏一样，我就是无法投入进去。
of the show my tool of the show is seven billion humans which is a video game a lot of people have suggested over the years programming video games you know like video games where you write computer programs as the game human resources yes wait what was that i'm sorry that's one of those games i think it's human resources oh yeah yeah so this is actually the sequel to that one oh okay oh human resource machine yeah that's right so so i've played so many of them at the request of listeners. And the only one I ever liked was Human Resource Machine. Like all the other ones I just couldn't get into.
就像其中一些游戏，你会觉得，哦，你得先阅读一本手册。哦，是这样的。我不知道这个。我剧透了你的梗。我很抱歉。不，不，不。所以当我接触到《Human Resource Machine》时，正如我所说，一位听众推荐了它，我想，好吧，这很简单。没有那么多指令，但它具有欺骗性的难，因为他们有这些延伸目标，比如用四条指令解决这个，诸如此类。
Like some of them it's like, oh, you have to read a manual first. Oh, it is. I didn't know this. I spoiled your punch. I'm sorry. No, no, no. And so I got to Human Resource Machine and someone, as I said, a listener recommended it. And I was like, OK, this is simple. There's not that many instructions, but it's deceptively hard because they have these like stretch goals, like solve this in four instructions and stuff.
这就是——所以我发现它非常、非常引人入胜，这是其他游戏所没有的。然后，然后我——不知怎么的，这个，我——不知怎么的，这个，我是自己发现的。我不记得具体是怎么回事了，哦，对了，它是 Humble Bundle 的一部分。所以我想当你听到这个时，Humble Bundle 已经过期了，不幸的是，但我通过 Humble Bundle 知道了这个。我最后甚至没有买这个套装，因为我想要安卓版的，而那个套装是给 PC 的。所以你在那上面没错过什么，但它太棒了。所以这个续集的运作方式是，你实际上控制着许多不同的人，使用相同的指令，但你知道，他们可以根据
And that's and so I found it really, really engaging in a way that I didn't find the other ones. And then and then I I somehow this, I, I somehow, I, this one, I came about on my own. I don't remember exactly how, Oh yeah, it was, it's part of a humble bundle. So I think the humble bundle will be expired by the time, uh, you're listening to this, unfortunately, but, uh, I found out about this through a humble bundle. I ended up actually not even getting the bundle because I wanted on Android and the bundle is for PC. So you're not missing anything there, but it's awesome. So the way this SQL works is you actually, you control like many different people with the same instructions, but you know, they can branch differently depending
他们的环境进行不同的分支。所以你利用这个技巧让一大群人同时做很多事情来实现某个更大的目标。所以，你知道的，第一关非常简单。就像，让每个人向右迈出一步。所以你只需要输入一个命令，向右迈出一小步。而所有人，有一大群人，他们都向右迈出一步。所以你开始理解，
on their environment. And so you use that trick to have a whole bunch of people do like a lot of things at the same time to accomplish some bigger goal. So like, you know, the first level is very simple. It's like, have everyone take a step to the right. And so you just put in one command, step right. And all these people, there's like a whole army of people, they all just take a step to the right. And so you kind of start to understand um you know what you're doing and then you start to see like oh okay this person couldn't take a step to the right they bumped into the wall and now that person is now shifted relative to everybody else and maybe you can use that to your advantage right so it's it's a really really fun game and i highly recommend it i think of all the programming games this one and its
你知道的，你在做什么，然后你开始看到，哦，好吧，这个人不能向右迈出一步，他们撞到了墙上，现在这个人相对于其他人发生了位移，也许你可以利用这一点来为自己谋利，对吧？所以这是一个非常、非常有趣的游戏，我强烈推荐它。我认为在所有的编程游戏中，这款游戏和它的
predecessor have been by far the most fun um i've tried to get my uh kids into it but uh i think it still feels a bit too out of reach for them it's a little bit too uh it requires a bit too much up front for for a for a six-year-old or whatever but actually now my son is older i might try again but yeah i highly recommend it if you want a programming game a game that we're programming is the game this one and the prequel are definitely the ones to start with nice i'm gonna i'm adding this to my list i i did like the i think i got all the way to the end i didn't do all the challenges but of human resource machine yeah actually it's the only game I think I have 100% in my life yeah all right my game I have not 100% is moss so I actually
前传可以说是最有趣的。我曾试图让我的孩子们玩这个，但我觉得对他们来说还是有点遥不可及。它有点太，它对一个六岁左右的孩子来说需要太多的前期投入，或者无论如何。但实际上现在我儿子长大了，我可能会再试一次。但是的，我强烈推荐它，如果你想要一个编程游戏，一个以编程为游戏的游戏，这款和前传绝对是首选。太棒了。我要把它加到我的清单里。我的确喜欢——我想我一直玩到了最后。我没有完成所有的挑战，但对于《Human Resource Machine》，是的，实际上这是我这辈子唯一一款我认为完成了 100% 的游戏。是的。好吧，我没有完成 100% 的游戏是《Moss》。所以我实际上
think this was a like normal game um like a normal pc game before like a first person game a platformer but i'm not i'm not 100 sure but this is i want to talk about the vr version the virtual reality version um and i did look it up because i i knew i would want to say it and so i checked it's available on oculus which is how i played it pc vr and the playstation vr so a variety of options there. Wait, real quick. What is PC VR? Oh, that just means like if you have like Oculus Rift or is it the HTC Vive or the Valve Index and you have it basically connected via like your computer is doing all of the playing and rendering
认为这是一款普通的游戏——就像在第一人称游戏、平台跳跃游戏之前的普通 PC 游戏，但我不是 100% 确定。但我这是想谈谈 VR 版本，虚拟现实版本。而且我查过，因为我知道我想说这个，所以我查了它在 Oculus 上的可用性，我是通过它玩的，还有 PC VR 和 PlayStation VR。所以那里有各种各样的选择。等等，快说。什么是 PC VR？哦，那只是意味着如果你有 Oculus Rift，或者是 HTC Vive，或者是 Valve Index，你基本上是通过像你的电脑在进行所有的游戏和渲染来连接它，
and then your headset is basically like a fancy monitor and like a gyroscope controller, it's feeding back oh interesting and so the headset itself doesn't have the the game power versus like an um oculus quest that um is basically like a cell phone doing all of the rendering and stuff uh in your headset i see so you're you're tethered to the computer and and i didn't even know about this so steam has has a vr headset yes wow well not steam a company that owns a valve valve the oh valve okay got it got it okay cool but you can buy um steam has vr games on it and like a interface for playing the vr games oculus for like the Rift has like a PC app that you run
然后你的头显基本上就像一个高档显示器和一个陀螺仪控制器，它将信息反馈回来。哦，有趣。所以头显本身没有游戏性能，相比之下，像 Oculus Quest 那样，它基本上就像一部手机，在你的头显里完成所有的渲染和各种东西。我明白了，所以你是绑在电脑上的。而且我甚至不知道这一点。所以 Steam 有 VR 头显吗？是的。哇，好吧，不是 Steam，是一家拥有 Valve 的公司，Valve 的，哦，Valve，明白了，明白了，好吧，酷。但你可以买，Steam 上有 VR 游戏，还有用于玩 VR 游戏的界面。Oculus 比如 Rift 有一个你可以运行的 PC 应用程序，
that allows you to do it as well. And you can hook your Oculus Quest to your computer or Quest 2, to your computer via like a really long USB-C cable with a whole bunch of caveats and actually have your computer do the rendering and send it. Or now they even have it wireless where your computer can do the rendering, which could be more powerful if you could find a GPU or already bought a GPU before they came impossible and super expensive. That's right. And like wirelessly stream the, basically the graphics to your headset and the controls from your headset back to the computer, which allows you to play games that wouldn't be available natively or wouldn't be able to run. So stuff like Half-Life Alyx, you can play on the Oculus if you play it on your computer and stream it to your headset.
它也允许你这样做。你可以通过一根非常长的 USB-C 线（带有各种注意事项）将你的 Oculus Quest 连接到你的电脑上，实际上让你的电脑进行渲染并发送过去。或者现在他们甚至有了无线功能，你的电脑可以进行渲染，如果你能找到 GPU，或者在 GPU 变得不可能买到且超级昂贵之前已经买了一个 GPU，这可能会更强大。没错。就像无线将图形传输到你的头显，并将来自头显的控制发回电脑一样，这允许你玩一些原本无法原生运行或无法运行的游戏。所以像《半条命：Alyx》这样的东西，如果你在电脑上玩并将其流式传输到头显，你就可以在 Oculus 上玩。
Yeah, that I've actually done. I bought on Amazon Prime Day, I bought a Wi-Fi extender. And so what I do is I have this Wi-Fi extender, which has its own SSID. And then the Wi-Fi extender is physically plugged into my desktop with a cat cable. And then I do the AirLink on the Oculus Quest. But when I do the AirLink, it's on the extended network. And so the Quest talks straight to the extender, which is like two feet away, which is wired to the PC. And so with that whole setup, air link works amazing uh yes my problem is my pc does not have a vr capable it's like the last generation before it was really like vr capable cards and then i went
是的，我确实这么做过。我在亚马逊 Prime Day 买了一个 Wi-Fi 扩展器。所以我做的是，我有了这个 Wi-Fi 扩展器，它有自己的 SSID。然后这个 Wi-Fi 扩展器通过网线物理插入我的台式机。然后在 Oculus Quest 上使用 AirLink。但当我使用 AirLink 时，它是在扩展网络上。所以 Quest 直接与相距两英尺、连接到 PC 的扩展器通信。通过整个设置，AirLink 的效果好得惊人。是的，我的问题是我的电脑没有 VR 功能。这就像是真正具备 VR 功能的显卡出现前的最后一代，然后我去
to upgrade once i got one and then found out like oh yeah that was a bad timing oh man um okay anyways moss so moss is a pretty interesting game and I actually play it and we stream the like what I'm seeing or what my kids are seeing to the TV. So we sort of played as kind of like a family, but it's like a platformer where you're a little mouse like running around and like going through sort of set pieces.
升级，当我买了一个后，发现——哦，天哪，时机太差了。哦，天哪。好吧，不管怎样，《Moss》。所以《Moss》是一款相当有趣的游戏，我实际上在玩它，我们将我看到的或我的孩子们看到的流式传输到电视上。所以我们有点像作为一个家庭一起玩，但它就像一个平台跳跃游戏，你是一只小老鼠，四处奔跑并穿过各种场景。
And so you as the, I don't know how you describe this, like you're controlling the animal, but your headset is like a sort of third person like set piece view so you're looking down on like a scene and you're controlling what happens but then uh you know you're sort of like once you get to this sort of like exit of that scene then it sort of like goes to the next scene kind of like what like a point and click adventures used to be okay okay yeah you like go to the edge of the screen and go to the next one but each scene is like a set and then you're like moving through the set it's like that but like in
所以作为，我不知道该怎么形容，你控制着动物，但你的头显就像一个第三人称视角的场景视图，所以你向下俯视一个场景，你控制发生的事情，但然后，你知道的，你有点像——一旦你到达那个场景的出口，它就会像切换到下一个场景一样，有点像以前的点击式冒险游戏。好吧，好吧，是的，你走到屏幕边缘去下一个，但每个场景都是一组，然后你穿过这些布景。它就像那样，但在
vr and it's a super cool and i don't like it's kind of nice like sometimes moving around and like walking and like all that stuff in vr is really fun but also can be sort of like uh you don't want to do that every time at least i don't sometimes it's like it's nice to it even tells you like sit in a chair and um you know just like have the cool visuals yeah yeah that's great so what is so is it literally a point and click adventure like you're trying to solve little mini puzzles um i mean it's a not like a point it's like a platformer oh okay got it got it so yeah so trying to yeah and there's like puzzles that you need to do and interact with there's probably
VR 中，这超级酷。而且我不喜欢——有时候在 VR 中四处移动、走动以及所有这些事情真的很有趣，但有时也可能有点——你不想每次都这样做，至少我不想。有时，它很好，甚至告诉你坐在椅子上，
a name for that kind of game but i it escapes me what genre that would be i think platformer yeah i mean there's there's a metroidvania where you're you're have kind of like you need to go back to previous ones yeah right yeah it's not like that. Okay, got it. Maybe it's just a straight platformer. It's like, I think they call it a puzzle platformer. Okay. Where like a regular platformer is like Mario,
然后，你知道的，只需欣赏酷炫的视觉效果。是的，是的，太棒了。所以，这真的是一个点击式冒险游戏吗？就像你试图解决小迷宫一样？我的意思是，这不是一个点击式，它就像一个平台跳跃游戏。哦，好吧，明白了，明白了。所以是的，所以试图——是的，有你需要完成和互动的谜题。这种游戏可能有一个名字，但我记不起那种流派是什么了。我认为是平台跳跃游戏。是的，我的意思是，有一种银河恶魔城 (Metroidvania)，你需要回到以前的地方。是的，对吧。是的，它不那样。好吧，明白了。也许它只是一个纯粹的平台跳跃游戏。就像，我想他们称之为解谜平台跳跃游戏。好吧。就像常规平台跳跃游戏是马里奥那样，
you're just stepping on things, but this is more like a puzzle platformer. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Cool, yeah, I'll have to check that out. I love those type of games. Well, I don't know about you, but I'm ready to take a, I mean, talk about vacation. Yeah, but I'm ready to talk about vacation. Yeah, I'm totally ready to take a vacation.
你只是踩在东西上，但这更像是一个解谜平台跳跃游戏。是的，是的，是的。酷，是的，我得去看看。我喜欢那种类型的游戏。好吧，我不知道你怎么样，但我准备去——我的意思是，谈谈度假。是的，但我准备谈谈度假。是的，我完全准备好去度假了。
We're going to take a vacation from the show, so I'll catch y'all. But I think vacations are extremely, extremely important, especially now. I think, Patrick, you'll probably echo this, but so many people on my team and at my company have maxed out their vacation and are literally just losing vacation days and not taking them. And I think there's this feeling like, well, I work from home. I can do the laundry while I'm at work. And so everything is kind of like a mix of, you know, working and not working. And so I don't really need a vacation or maybe I'm going to wait until, you know, COVID is over.
我们将从节目中休假，所以我会联系大家的。但我认为度假极其、极其重要，尤其是现在。我想，帕特里克，你可能会对此产生共鸣，但我团队和公司的很多人都休满了假，实际上正在失去假期天数却不去休假。而且我觉得有一种感觉，嗯，我在家里工作。我在工作时可以洗衣服。所以一切都像是工作和不工作的混合体。所以我真的不需要度假，或者也许我要等到，你知道的，新冠结束。
But we're really starting to see the effects of that. And so I felt like it's a good time to really talk about why we do vacations, how to take a good vacation, and what are sort of the different kinds of vacations and how you have to act differently when you're you know planning for one of those yeah i think company to company vacation policies vary wildly between the united states and not united states europe asia like also tons of variation in the expectations and culture around vacations but as yeah i'll echo it as being said that like it's it is important to not burn out to take time for yourself or your family to do something fun i
但我们真的开始看到这种做法的影响了。所以我觉得现在是时候真正谈谈为什么我们要度假，如何度过一个好的度假，以及不同类型的假期的种类是什么，当你准备度假时你必须如何采取不同的行动。是的，我认为不同公司之间的休假政策在美国和非美国地区（欧洲、亚洲）差异很大，围绕假期的期望和文化也有很多差异。但正如，是的，我呼应这一点，即不要精疲力竭，抽出时间留给自己或家人去做一些有趣的事情是非常重要的。
think a lot of people are saving it up right now under the current environment so they just want to do something super fun and all the fun things seem like you can't do them right now like going on the going on international flights or grand trips involves like a lot of extra, um, uh, we don't say like getting COVID checked and risks and people are just, you know, not comfortable doing it. So I feel like people are saving up, but I mean that what I always find, and I don't, we don't have this called out to talk about as I was talking about now, but like sometimes it's, you don't think you need a vacation until it's too late.
我认为很多人在当前环境下都在攒着假期，所以他们只想做一些超级有趣的事情，而所有有趣的事情看起来好像你现在都不能做，比如去进行国际航班旅行或宏大的旅行涉及很多额外的，嗯，我们不说像新冠检测和风险，人们只是，你知道的，觉得不舒服去做。所以我觉得人们都在攒着假期，但我的意思是，我总是发现——虽然我们没有把这作为待讨论的事项，就像我现在正在谈论的——但有时，你直到为时已晚才觉得自己需要度假。
Like by the time you realize like I really need a vacation, then you need to plan it. You know, you're going to like schedule your time off. And then by the time you get there, you're like way past when you should have done it. Yeah, yeah, exactly. Yeah. I think we can start it off with this article that I'll link to in the show notes. It talks about the seven types of rest. And I really found this powerful. I read this a while back and I was able to dig it up. The first type of rest is physical rest. I mean, that's what most people think about. Like, you know, you run a few miles or something and then, okay, I need to rest. The second type is mental rest. And so, you know, you can imagine this pretty easily too. Like you do a chess tournament or something and then
比如等你意识到“我真的需要度假”的时候，你就得开始计划了。你知道的，你要安排好休假时间。然后等你真正到了度假的时候，你会发现自己早就该去度假了。对，对，完全是这样。对。我觉得我们可以从这篇文章开始聊起，我会在节目文稿里附上链接。它讲的是七种休息方式。我觉得这篇文章真的很有启发性。我前段时间读过，后来又把它翻了出来。第一种休息是身体上的休息。我是说，这也是大多数人想到的那种。比如，你跑步跑了几英里或者干了别的体力活，然后就会觉得，好吧，我需要休息了。第二种是精神上的休息。所以，你可以很轻松地想象出这种情景。比如你参加了一个国际象棋锦标赛之类的活动，然后
afterwards you're really tired. Right. Debug my program. Yeah, yeah, exactly. Yeah. You, you play a human resource machine and then you need to rest. The third type of rest is sensory rest. This is really, really important. You know, I feel like, uh, um, and we'll talk about this in more detail, but I feel like, especially with, um when I have a vacation, it's the opposite of sensory rest. So for me to get sensory rest, I have to go back to work. And that just means, sensory rest can mean different things to different people. It could mean bright lights and the computer screen in your face. That's one type of sensory overload. It could be just a lot of people around you all talking and having different conversations at the
结束后你真的觉得累极了。对。就像去给我的程序找Bug一样。对，对，完全是这样。对。你玩了一局《人力资源机器》这类游戏，然后你就需要休息了。第三种休息是感官上的休息。这真的、真的是非常重要。你知道，我觉得，呃，而且我们稍后会更详细地讨论这一点，但我觉得，特别是在，呃，每当我度假的时候，那种状态其实跟感官休息完全相反。所以对我来说，要获得感官休息，我反而得回去上班。这其实意味着，感官休息对不同的人来说意味着不同的事情。它可能意味着强烈的灯光和直面电脑屏幕。这是感官超载的一种。也可能意味着你身边围着很多人，都在同时大声说话、聊着不同的话题。
same time. And you kind of trying to listen to all of them. But you know, all of that stuff can, can fatigue you on, in that dimension. There's creative rest where, you know, you, you might feel compelled to start a new project or invent something new. Like maybe your job right now is to find the next big thing. And so you're just spending all your time trying to, um, figure out like what was the right path and you can get burnt out in that way. Um, emotional rest and, uh, spiritual rest. Um, so yeah, take a look at this article, but I felt like we can kind of use that to set the stage for, you know, like, like, well, the biggest reason to go on vacation, which is to, to get that rest so that you can, you know, come back with the energy you need to do the next thing.
而你还得试着去听清他们每个人说的话。但你知道，所有这些事情都可能会在那个维度上让你感到疲惫。还有创造性休息，你知道的，你可能会觉得非得开始一个新项目或发明点新东西不可。比如你目前的工作就是寻找下一个重大突破。所以你把所有时间都花在，呃，搞清楚正确的方向是什么上面，你完全可能会因此而精疲力竭。呃，还有情感休息，呃，精神休息。所以，是的，大家可以去看看这篇文章，但我觉得我们可以借此来为今天的话题做个铺垫，也就是，你知道的，比如，人们去度假的最大原因，其实就是为了获得那种休息，这样你才能带着完成下一项工作所需的能量回归。
Yeah, I mean, I think like I was mentioning before, like, but sometimes by the time you need that rest, the sort of vacation, which I think is a great opportunity. So some of those kinds of rest, you probably should be doing continuously. But a vacation provides a time to step away. I think, you know, just put stuff on hold. And I also, I think it's different. And taking a vacation, when other people are continuing to get the work done and you're stepping away from it than like when like let's say at you know christmas time here in the united states like maybe your company gives like a week off and everybody has off i think those two things are actually slightly different and mentally how like it's good to allow other people to make
是的，我是说，我觉得就像我刚才提到的，有时候等你真正需要那种休息时，也就是那种我认为是非常棒的机会的度假。所以其中某些休息方式，你可能应该一直在做。但度假提供了一个抽身而出的时间。我觉得，你知道的，就是把手头的事情先搁置一下。而且我也觉得，这其实不一样。去度假时，其他人还在继续推进工作，而你从工作中抽身出来，这跟那种情况不一样，比如说，假设在美国的圣诞节期间，也许你的公司会放假一周，所有人都在放假，我觉得这两件事在心理上其实略有不同，比如，能够让其他人去
progress on something and come back and see like the world turns without you versus like everybody takes off and then you come back and everybody's starting up again. Yeah. Yeah. That's so true. Yeah. I think, I think one of the sort of anti-patterns to a good vacation is, is where, you know, you take the time off and you come back and you're two weeks behind. Right. And it's like, you didn't really take a vacation. You just like procrastinated, right? I mean, it's not a vacation. I just need your deadlines to get closer. Yeah, yeah, exactly. So reasons, we should talk a little bit about reasons
在某项工作上取得进展，然后你回来后发现“世界离开你照样运转”，这跟所有人都同时放假、然后你回来后大家又得重新开始，感觉是不一样的。对，对。太对了。对。我觉得，好假期的“反模式”之一就是，你休假回来了，结果发现自己落后了两周的工作。对吧？这就好像你根本没度假，你只是在拖延，对吧？我是说，这根本不算度假。我只是让你的截止日期更近了而已。对，对，完全是这样。所以，关于原因，我们应该稍微聊聊
to not take a vacation. So, I mean, a lot of people aren't taking vacations. And so we should talk about what those reasons are because they are real. I mean, they're rational. If people feel like they can lose context, you can miss an opportunity. Maybe there's a plan to have, let's say, an intern and you took a vacation when the intern applications went out. Or you took a vacation in the summer and so your intern wouldn't have a manager, right? So you can miss opportunities to do things that
不度假的原因。所以，我是说，很多人其实并不休假。我们应该讨论一下这些原因是什么，因为它们确实存在。我是说，这些理由很合理。如果人们觉得休假会失去对项目的了解，或者错过机会。也许原本有个计划，比如要招一个实习生，而你却在实习生申请开放的时候去度假了。或者你在夏天度假，结果导致你的实习生没有了负责人，对吧？所以你可能会错过一些机会，无法去做那些
are seasonal or just maybe just serendipitous, but they just happen while you're gone. And you can slip on your deadline, right? If you have a six-month goal and you take a month off, but you don't change the goal or you don't plan around that, then you still have six months of work to do. And so these are reasons that people will give for not taking a vacation. And those are valid reasons, but I think with the right planning and the right mental model, you can ameliorate a lot of these issues. Yeah. I mean, talking about planning, I mean, I think there is some stuff you should do. So,
季节性的事情，或者纯粹是机缘巧合但偏偏在你离开时发生的事情。而且你的截止日期可能会延误，对吧？如果你有一个六个月的目标，而你休假了一个月，但你没有调整目标，也没有为此做好规划，那么你依然有六个月的工作要做。所以，这些就是人们不休假的理由。这些理由虽然成立，但我认为只要有正确的规划和正确的心态，你就可以很大程度上缓解这些问题。是的。我是说，说到规划，我觉得确实有一些事情是你应该做的。所以，
you know, making sure that you've handed off responsibility for stuff you're going to do. So like Jason mentioned, that it's not just like you deferred something for a week and then everything is piling up, you know, making sure other people are able to help the work that you've done. So if you're a manager, that means something different than if you're a director.
你知道的，要确保把你准备去做的那些事情的责任交接好。就像杰森提到那样，不能只是把某件事推迟一周，然后所有事情都堆积起来，你知道的，要确保其他人能够协助完成你之前做过的工作。所以，如果你是一个经理，这和如果你是一个总监，意义是完全不同的。
It means something different if you're like a, you know, individual contributor. But, you know, making sure that people kind of know what you are doing and that's an important thing in general. I'll say it here too. I think people going on
如果你是一个，你知道的，独立贡献者，那这代表的意义也不同。但是，你知道的，要确保大家大致了解你在做什么，这在平时也是一件很重要的事。我在这里也想说，我认为员工去
vacation is important for preparing for unexpected absences. So sometimes someone can go on a vacation and you can plan for it, but some people just get sick or have, you know, it'd be horrible, but someone could be incapacitated from working for an extended amount of time or even pass away or whatever. Right. And as like in the scale of that, obviously like your work stuff, isn't that important, but like, I mean, making sure that if someone has to step away unexpectedly, that the team doesn't crumble while they're gone. And part of that taking vacations is sort of like repeatedly making sure the
度假对于应对突发缺勤非常重要。有时候，有人去度假了，你可以提前做好规划；但有时候人们就是会生病，或者遇到——虽然这很糟糕，但有人可能会因为长期无法工作而丧失劳动能力，甚至不幸离世等等。对吧。从这个角度来看，很显然，你的工作其实没那么重要，但是，我是说，要确保如果有人必须突发离职或请假，团队也不会在他离开时陷入瘫痪。而休假的其中一部分意义，就是不断地去确保团队
team knows how to cover or, Oh, while you were gone, no one was able to log into that system. So like we need you to make sure you have have the credentials put somewhere or other people have access. Making sure your code is documented in a way that if someone else has to go in there and debug an issue, that they're not screaming at you where you can hear them on your vacation. And then also making sure that you, as bad as it is, like certain roles and responsibilities, like Jason just mentioned these reasons why not. Sometimes you need to decide like how available will you be to work while you're on your vacation
知道该如何补位，或者，“哦，在你离开期间，没有人能够登录那个系统。”所以我们需要确保你把凭证放在某个地方，或者其他人也有访问权限。要确保你的代码文档写得足够清楚，这样万一别人不得不接手去排查问题时，他们不会在度假时听到你在心里痛骂他们。然后还要确保你——尽管这听起来可能不太好——但对于某些角色和职责，就像杰森刚才提到的那些不休假的理由一样，有时候你需要决定：在度假期间，你对工作的可联系程度到底是多少？
and different people decide differently about this. Some people say, you know, if it's an emergency, you can call me. Some people say, hey, let me know about X, Y, or Z or Z or I'm gonna check in each day or every other day some people are like I'm basically dunking my phone in the ocean and like I'll buy a new one when I get back so you know decide upfront like what the expectations are with your team about how open you are to being thing but I it is important to my thing is like if you're going on vacation it really should be you're not checking checking your chat rooms, you're not checking your emails every day. But maybe if there really is a legitimate reason, someone could reach out to you and get a hold of you.
不同的人对此有不同的决定。有些人说：“如果发生紧急情况，你可以打电话给我。”有些人说：“嘿，遇到X、Y、Z这些情况请告诉我，或者我每天或每隔一天会查看一下消息。”还有些人会说：“我基本上是把手机扔进大海里了，等我回来再买个新的。”所以，你知道的，要在事前和团队沟通好期望值，明确你对被联系的开放程度。不过我觉得，我的看法是，如果你去度假了，那就真的应该做到不刷聊天室、不每天查看电子邮件。但也许如果真的有合理的紧急原因，别人还是可以联系到你的。
But also, do you take your work laptop if you have one or not? If you don't take your work laptop, it may limit how much you could do. And so making sure that like lines are drawn around that with your team, with your manager and getting all that settled up front. Yeah. We should talk a little bit here about, you know, as personally, my view on this has evolved over the years. I used, well, there was a time when we worked at a place where when you were on vacation, you didn't have access to anything. And so that kind of made the decision for us. Back in the day. Back in my day. But now, you know, so starting from the time where we had control over like how much we wanted to do on vacation, I used to kind of bring, yeah, bring my work laptop, bring my work phone and just be totally plugged in on vacation. And then slowly I've been moving
此外，你带不带工作笔记本电脑？如果不带工作笔记本电脑，可能会限制你能做的事情。所以要确保与你的团队、你的经理划清界限，并在事前把这些都敲定。对。我们在这里应该稍微聊聊，随着时间的推移，我个人的看法也发生了变化。我以前——曾经有一段时间，我们在一个这样的地方工作：当你去度假时，你是没有任何系统访问权限的。所以这直接替我们做了决定。那是过去的事了。我那个年代的事。但现在，你知道的，从我们能够自己控制度假时想做多少工作的那个阶段开始，我曾经会，是的，把工作笔记本电脑带上，把工作手机带上，在度假期间完全处于连线状态。然后我慢慢地开始
away from that model. And I've gotten to the point now where I literally, I don't bring anything and I don't have any connection at all. And what I found for myself is as I did less and less work while I was on vacation, my work quality also went way down because I would have less context. And so I would just make bad decisions and do bad things. And so I realized at some point I was like, okay, I'm on vacation. And instead of working 100%, I'm doing 10% work that is terrible and destructive. And so I got to the point where I'm on vacation, I'm off the grid. And I give people my personal phone number if there's something really urgent,
脱离那种模式。现在的我已经到了这样一个阶段：我真的什么都不带，也完全没有任何连接。我发现，随着我在度假期间做的工作越来越少，我的工作质量反而大大提升了，因为这样我会有更少的上下文信息。于是我就会做出糟糕的决定，干出糟糕的事情。所以在某个时刻我意识到，好吧，我在度假。与其带着100%的心思去工作，结果却做出可怕且具有破坏性的10%的糟糕工作，不如彻底放空。所以我最终决定，在度假期间，我直接彻底失联。我把我的个人手机号码留给别人，以防万一有什么真的很紧急的事情，
but in practice, it's almost never, only a handful of times has it ever come up, and that's kind of where I've evolved to, but how have you evolved, Patrick? Where are you at? Yeah, I mean, I think it changes over time. My current thing that works for me, I think, is here's my phone number.
但实际上，这种情况几乎从来没有发生过，只有寥寥几次。这就是我心态演变的过程，不过你是怎么演变的呢，帕特里克？你现在是怎么处理的？对，我是说，我觉得这会随着时间而改变。目前对我有效的方法是，把我的电话号码留给他们。
I mean, that's everyone's personal decision, but here's my phone number. Look, if something comes up, where and I'm in a position where I, you know, manage some people now, so there's a little bit different. Like, I tell them, like, look, if there's a problem where it would really benefit from me being involved, like use your discretion to the people on my team or to my manager, like call me, I'd rather handle an HR issue or whatever, even if I'm on vacation, then to come back and have it had been an issue for a week. And that being really stressful to a person or the team or to whatever. And so I tell them like, look, you can text me or
我是说，这是每个人的个人决定，但我会留下我的电话号码。听着，如果有事情发生，而且我处于一个——你知道的，我现在管理着一些人，所以情况稍微有点不同。我告诉他们：“听着，如果有这样一个问题，如果我能参与其中会对事情有很大帮助的话，请你们团队的人或者我的经理自行判断——给我打电话。”我宁愿在度假时处理一个人事问题或诸如此类的事情，也不愿度假回来后发现这个问题已经搁置了一周，从而给当事人、团队或其他人带来巨大的压力。所以我告诉他们：“听着，你可以发短信给我，或者
you can call me, but I tell them otherwise, I'm not going to check my emails. If you send me an email and just maybe he'll check it, I'm not going to. And so I don't, I don't check my email. I sign out of our chat app, you know, and if someone needs to SMS me or needs to call me, like I tell them that they can, they've been respectful of that. Now that could vary workplace to workplace. And some workplaces I know people do that and they would get abused and it would just be constantly being called. And, um, you know, there's a lot more context we should talk about there, but like that, that's my personal thing. Although I will say that, you know, while we're talking about vacations, there's other kinds of things like if you, if someone were to pass away, you're on bereavement leave, or you're on sick leave. For me personally, like when I'm doing
可以打电话给我，但我同时也告诉他们，除此之外，我不会查看电子邮件。如果你给我发了电子邮件，指望我什么时候可能会看一眼，那我压根不会看。”所以我不——我不看电子邮件。我退出了我们的聊天应用，你知道的，如果有人必须发短信或打电话联系我，我告诉过他们可以这样做，而他们也一直很尊重这一点。当然，这在不同的工作场所可能会有所不同。据我所知，在某些工作场所，如果员工这么做就会被滥用，电话会打个不停。而且，你知道的，我们其实还有很多相关的背景可以讨论，但这确实是我个人的做法。不过我要说的是，在我们讨论度假的同时，还有其他类型的情况，比如，如果有人不幸离世，你需要请丧假，或者你需要请病假。就我个人而言，当我在经历
those things, if I'm unable to, like Jason said, do quality work, then I'll be off. But I have a tendency, like if I'm just sick, I will check in on email or check my chats just in case I could be helpful to someone. I'm just not up to working a full day. Yeah, that makes sense. Yeah, I think I'm the same way. When I'm sick, I usually work just, I use the sick day to basically say,
这些情况时，如果像杰森说的那样，我无法进行高质量的工作，那我就彻底休息。但我有个倾向，如果我只是生病了，我会查看邮件或聊天记录，以防我能帮上别人什么忙。我只是没有状态去工作整整一天。是的，这说得通。对，我想我也是这样的。我生病的时候通常也会工作，只不过——我请病假基本上是为了说明，
look, I can't be 100%. But there are some days, yeah, where I mark myself as sick, but I'm like 99% available. But yeah, for vacation, I had a phase where I was like that, where I basically said, here's my thing. If there's some HR issue, let me know. But then what I found is that while I'm on vacation, I kind of make bad decisions. You know, it's like, it's like I'm there on the beach, you know, uh, drinking margaritas or something. And then someone has some HR issue and then I have to make a decision right then and
听吧，我无法达到100%的状态。但确实有些日子，我把自己标记为生病，但其实99%的时间都在线。不过话说回来，关于度假，我也有过那样的一个阶段，当时我基本上是这么做的：“这是我的联系方式，如果有任何人事问题，请告诉我。”但后来我发现，当我在度假时，我往往会做出糟糕的决定。你知道的，这感觉就像，我就在海滩上，喝着玛格丽塔酒什么的，然后突然有人抛出了一个人事问题，我必须当场做出决定。
there. And usually, you know, what happens when you're on vacation is people will, they'll only reach you if there's an emergency. And so what you end up with is you end up with just emergencies and it gives you like a really odd, uh, lens through which you view your job because it just, it's just like, it's like weekly emergencies, but, but no context. And so, uh, yeah. And then when I look back on how did I handle those emergencies and like, you know, what actually transpired, I was like, yeah, I probably should have just like not handled it and do it, done nothing until I got back. Um, but, but yeah, that's very small sample size. I mean, we only go on so many vacations a year, right? So, but yeah, and that very small sample size I found. So, so I've gone this way. We'll
通常情况下，当你在度假时发生的事情是，人们只有在遇到紧急情况时才会联系你。所以你最后接触到的全都是紧急情况，这会给你提供一个非常奇特的视角来看待你的工作，因为感觉全都是每周一次的紧急情况，却没有任何上下文信息。所以，是的。后来当我回过头来看自己是怎么处理这些紧急情况的，以及实际上发生了什么时，我心想，是的，我当时可能应该直接不管它，什么都别做，等我回来再说。不过，不过是的，这只是个非常小的样本量。我是说，我们一年到头也就去度假那么几次，对吧？所以，但是在那个非常小的样本量中我发现了这一点。所以我现在改变了方式。我们
see how it goes. My most recent vacation, which I just got back from, was a week. And I was totally off the grid for that week. And so far, so good. But you still have a job and nothing burned down. Came back, still have a job. I think if I took a long vacation and I came back and something really went wrong and I just let it go wrong, I think then I'll have that perspective and I came back and something really went wrong and I, you know, just let it go wrong. I think then I'll have that perspective and I'll have the full 360. I mean, I'll say here too, some people may be thinking like, oh, it must be nice. I mean, I do know there are situations where deciding you want to take a vacation is something you need to negotiate with your, you know, sort of
拭目以待吧。我最近的一次度假，也就是刚结束的那次，为期一周。在那一周里我彻底与世隔绝、全面失联。目前看来，一切都挺好的。你依然保住了工作，而且也没有什么东西烧毁。回来后，工作还在。我想，如果我休了一个长假，回来后发现真的出了大乱子，而我却选择任由它出错，我想到了那个时候我就会有那种视角，并且能够获得完整的360度全景体验。我是说，我在这里也想说，有些人可能会想：“哦，那一定很美好。”我是说，我确实知道有些情况下，决定去度假是需要你和你的，你知道的，管理层去协商的事情。有时候可能会遇到冲刺期，或者有些时候你觉得自己真的很需要休假却又无法成行。听着，那种情况确实是存在的，我不会否认有时候我明明非常需要或想要休假却还是没有去，因为当时的时机确实不合适。但就像所有事情一样，你知道的，你的工作生活平衡是因人而异的。
management. And there could be a crunch time time or could be something where you really feel you need to take a vacation and you just can't and look those situations you know do happen I won't say that there aren't times that I probably didn't take a vacation despite really needing or wanting to because it just wasn't appropriate but like with everything I mean you know your work-life balance is something that varies person to person. And as Jason and I are alluding to, like, I mean, I think that over time, like how I've approached work life balance, how I've approached these choices has changed, not just because I'm just at a different place in my life, not because necessarily just work has changed, but I've
正如杰森和我所暗示的，随着时间的推移，我对待工作生活平衡的方式、我做出这些选择的方式都在改变，这不仅仅是因为我正处于人生的不同阶段，也不仅仅是因为工作本身变了，而是我变了。是的，这也是事实。所以我觉得你必须为自己、为家人、为工作做出正确的度假决定。如果你觉得：“听着，我无法获得真正需要的假期，而且公司不让我去，”如果你对自己诚实的话，你知道的，也许你得考虑换个工作了。但我并不认为仅仅因为公司说：“哦，那个假期我们得拒绝，那是糟糕的一周，你能推迟几周再休吗？”这就算是不合理的。这里面可能确实有正当的理由。是的。完全说得通。对，我想，呃，我是说，我一直都在各种研究实验室工作，所以我其实已经很久没有经历过产品开发周期了，但确实，
changed. Yeah, that's true, too. And so I think you got to make decisions about vacation that are right for you, for your family, for your work. And if, and if you're like, look, I can't take the vacations I really need to, and work won't let me. And, and you're being honest with yourself, you know, maybe you got to find a new job, but I don't think just because work says, you know, Oh, you know, that's not, we deny that vacation. Like that's a bad week. Can you take it a few weeks later? I mean, there could be legitimate reasons for that. Yeah. Yeah. Totally makes sense. Yeah. I think, uh, I mean, I've been in sort of research labs the whole time, so I haven't really, it's been a long time since I was part of like a product cycle, but yeah,
这会影响到你，你知道的，你什么时候该去度假。总的来说，如果你对事情的起伏节奏有很好的把握，你就知道什么时候该去度假。总的来说，如果你对事情的起伏节奏有很好的把握，很显然，最好总是在工作比较清闲的时候去度假。但是，哦，还有一件事是，是的，当我——我高中时曾练过赛艇，虽然我们可能都知道赛艇运动其实很简单，就是划船。基本上大家都在同一起跑线上排成一列，然后所有人朝着一个直线方向划船。这就好比是用手划着船进行直线加速赛。所以你可能会觉得，哦，这很简单，大家只要以最快的速度划船就行了。
that will, that will affect your, uh, you know, when you should take a vacation. And in general, you know, if you have a good read on the ebb and flow of things, you know, when you should take a vacation and in general, you know, if you have a good read on the ebb and flow of things, you know, it's obviously always best to take a vacation when it's a slow time. But, uh, Oh, another thing is, is yeah, when I, I used to do crew in high school, which we all don't know crew is very similar. It's just rowing a boat. So basically you all start in the same place in a line and you all row a boat in a straight line. It's like drag racing with a boat that you row with your hands. And so you might think, well, oh, it's it's you just everyone just row the boat as fast as they can.
但实际上在赛艇运动中，你会遇到一种叫做“10桨爆发”（Power 10）的东西，也就是连续10次非常有力的划水，所有人同时进行这10桨的爆发。这样就不会出现某一个人拼命划、遭遇各种阻力，而其他人却没这么做的情况了。对吧。所以，哪怕是在一个只有一个单一目标——那就是以最快速度直线前进的事情中，依然会有低谷期，对吧？会有起伏跌宕。所以，人们逐渐明白，如果你有那种清闲的时期和全力爆发的时期，你反而能更快地达到目标。因此，工作也是同样的道理。我是说，你要工作二十年、三十年、四十年，谁知道呢。所以，呃，你知道的，你需要抽出那些休息时间，
But actually in crew, you'd have these things called power 10 where you'd have 10 like really powerful strokes and everyone does a power 10 at the same time. That way you don't have one person rowing really hard, encountering all sorts of resistance and the other people not. Right. And so, you know, even in something where it only has one singular goal, which is to go in a straight line as fast as possible, even then you have lulls, right? You have ebbs and flows. So, you know, people have learned that that's sort of, you end up getting to the goal faster if you have sort of those slow times and those power times. And so, and so it's the same thing with work. I mean, you're going to be working for who knows, 20, 30 years, 40 years. And so, um, you know, you're going to need to take those breaks so
这样你才能在之后的日子里迎来真正能量爆发的时刻。这一切其实都是，你知道的，哪怕你是一个100%争强好胜、以事业为导向的人，你依然会发现，拥有合适的假期是尽快到达终点线的关键。那么，一旦你结束了假期——我们先不谈大家去过的那些令人赞叹的地方——现在你回来了。然后呢，你知道的，当你回来后，你必须把落下的工作补回来。我觉得有时候，人们之所以不想去度假，纯粹是因为害怕假期结束回来后面临的烂摊子。呃，是的。但我认为，实际上你回来后要做的事情，以及有多少工作等着你去做，大概能告诉你
that you can have those like really powerful moments later on. It's all kind of, you know, even if you are totally 100% type A, you know, career oriented, you still like having the right vacation is key to, you know, getting to the finish line as quickly as possible. What about once you have taken your vacation, which we shouldn't talk about all the awesome places we've all gone, but now we're back. And then like you know when you get back you gotta catch back up i think sometimes not going on vacation is just the dread of what's gonna happen when you get back um yeah but i think actually the things you would do when you get back and how it's like how bad but how much there is to do probably is something that tells you
这样一个道理：也许有些事情是需要改变的，哪怕是在你的日常工作中。比如，你回来后发现有几百封未读邮件需要处理。我是说，也许这就是你的工作，也许这是无可避免的。但对我来说，很多邮件其实是我大概永远不需要了解的，真的没必要看，我回来后也不需要知道。所以，通过设置过滤器，把这些邮件归入不同的文件夹，让我能够轻松地进行整理，并非常快速地浏览那些真正重要的内容。我不喜欢邮件的一点是，或者说至少我们工作中的邮件是这样的——设置过滤器把它们归入不同的文件夹，让我能够轻松地进行整理，并非常快速地浏览那些真正重要的内容。我不喜欢邮件的一点是，或者说至少我们工作中的邮件是这样的：各种事情都混杂在一起，对吧？所以你会收到个人问题，
like maybe there's stuff to change around like even in your day-to-day so one thing like you come back and you have hundreds of unread emails you need to go through i mean maybe that's your job maybe that's like something unavoidable but for me a lot of those emails are stuff i probably never needed to know about not really and i don't need to know about when i get back so having filters that put those into buckets that i can easily organize and skim through very quickly for things that are like one thing i don't like about email or at least how our email is at filters that put those into buckets that I can easily organize and skim through very quickly for things that are like, one thing I don't like about email, or at least how our email is at work is like, things are just intermixed, right? So you're just getting like a personal question,
然后你会收到自动生成的邮件，然后你还会收到，你知道的，总之组织得非常糟糕。拥有规则、过滤器或搜索功能，可以让你把所有相关的事情一次性全部处理完。这是你回来后应对海量邮件时需要做的事情，但其实这也应该是你平时就应该一直在做的事。是的。从度假回来后做这件事的好处在于，你积压了大量的未读邮件。所以，这其实成了一种去过滤邮件的动力，因为你反正也读不完。而如果你是一封接一封地阅读刚刚收到的邮件，你就会觉得：“哦，我已经读过这个了，我就不设置过滤了。”但实际上，如果你有大约20封这样的邮件——我不知道，这可能取决于你使用的邮件应用。但在我的工作中，大家使用的是Outlook。
and then you're getting like an automated email, and then you're getting, you know, and it's just the organization isn't good. Having rules or filters or searches you can do where you kind of take care of everything related all at one time. Something you need to do to manage the bulk when you get back, but something you probably should do all the time. Yeah. The nice thing about doing it when you get back from vacation is you have a lot of unread emails. And so there's, there's like an incentive to filter things because you don't have to read them. Whereas if you're reading like emails as they come in, it's like, Oh, I've already read this. I'm not going to filter it. But it's like, yeah, if you have like 20 of these, and I don't know, it might depend on the email app you use. But for my job, they use Outlook.
在Outlook中，你可以按住Ctrl键点击多封邮件，然后选择“像这样过滤”。它就会弹出一系列能够捕获所有这些邮件、同时又不会捕获过头规则。所以，我是说，你可以根据发件人进行过滤，也可以根据主题进行过滤。所以这就好比，拥有一堆未读邮件反而给了你一个设置相当全面的规则的机会。
With Outlook, you can like control click several emails and then say filter like this. And it'll come up with like various rules that capture all of those emails without capturing too much. And so, I mean, you could filter based on who sent it, you could filter based on the subject. And so that's like having a bunch of unread emails gives you like an opportunity to set some rules that are pretty comprehensive.
我是说，另一件对于程序员来说——你们大多数人可能都是程序员——当你回来时，我认为很重要的一点是，要通读在你离开期间发生的代码变更。了解都有哪些改变。如果有人在寻找反馈，
I mean, I think the other thing, if you're a programmer, which most of you probably are, when you get back, I think it's important to look through the code changes that have happened while you're gone. Catch up on what's changed. If anyone was looking for feedback
或者如果你有什么意见，要确保你大致了解你将要重新接手的项目的现状。如果有什么设计文档出炉了，或者发生了任何规划调整，确保你去和关键人物交流，弄清楚在你离开期间到底发生了什么。另外一件事是，最近尤其是通过——至少对我的公司来说是这样——随着居家办公的普及，聊天消息变得更多了。所以试着回过头去查看聊天记录，
or if you have any comments, making sure that you sort of kind of know what the state is of what you're walking back into. If any design documents have come back out, whatever planning has happened, making that you you talk to key people and sort of figure out what's gone on since you've been there another thing is like more recently especially with the at least that's from my company with with work from home a lot more chats that happen and so trying to go back to the chats
看看大家都在讨论什么，有没有什么是我错过了、需要去跟进的。把这些全部过一遍，对重回工作状态的第一天来说至关重要。是的，这完全说得通。是的，我想，呃，是的，还有一件事是专门针对居家办公的——或者也许不光是居家办公，但对于居家办公尤其重要——那就是做好过渡。你知道的，比如，呃，差不多就像是留出一些时间。如果你打算，比方说，去进行一次盛大的家庭旅行，然后你一直工作到家庭旅行前一天晚上10点，紧接着第二天早上5点就要坐在车里开始跨国自驾，那你
and see like what got talked about was there anything that I I kind of missed that I should follow up on and just getting through all of that that sort of like first day back is uh important to getting back up to speed yeah that totally makes sense yeah i think um um yeah another thing specific to work from home or maybe even maybe even not specific but especially important when you work from home is, is, is getting that transition right. You know, like, uh, almost like, like having some time, if you're going to, let's say, go on a big family trip, then if you're working right up until, you know, 10 PM before the family trip, and then 5 AM the next morning, you're in the car, like driving cross country, like you're
会感到压力极大的。对吧。所以你会觉得，建立某种缓冲期非常重要。根据你的实际情况，也许你需要在假期开始前多请一两天假，或者也许你，你知道的，上半天班之类的，这取决于你的具体情况。但总之，你希望在假期开始前得到充分的休息。这就回到了那个TED演讲的主题，对吧？度假会在某些维度上让你精疲力竭，但在另一些维度上为你充电。所以，我是说，这其实也取决于度假的形式。比如，如果你选择那种呆在家里打电子游戏的假期，那简直棒极了。这才是最好的。宅度假（Staycation）简直绝了。但如果你进行的是一种，呃，类似于探险的假期——我不知道该怎么称呼它，某种远征。
going to be really stressed out. Right. And so you almost, it's important to have like some type of buffer, you know, depending on your situation, maybe you need to take an extra day or two off before the, before the vacation, or maybe you, um, you know, do a half day or something, depending on how your circumstances are, but you want to be rested before your vacation starts. And this gets back to that Ted talk, right? The vacation is going to exhaust you in, in dimensions, in some dimensions and recharge you in others. And so, I mean, and this depends too on the vacation. Like if you have a vacation where you just get to stay home and play video games, that's awesome. That's the best. The staycation is amazing. But if you have a, uh, like an adventure vacation, I don't know what you'd call it, but some kind of expedition.
如果那是你的假期，也许你要去滑雪，这会在体力上让你筋疲力竭，之类的。对吧。很多假期都会在不同的方面让你感到疲惫。所以实际上，你甚至需要从度假中“缓过劲来”休息一下。你刚才稍微提到了度假的类型，比如，你是坐在沙滩上发呆，还是在攀登乞力马扎罗山顶，这些显然是不一样的。我觉得度假的另一个不同之处在于时长。杰森和我开始录音前曾简短地讨论过这一点：如果是非常短的假期，我们觉得可能是几天时间，大概不到一周，那么人们可能就会把事情先
If that's your vacation, maybe you're going to go skiing and it's going to really physically exhaust you or something. Right. Like a lot of vacations are going to exhaust you in different ways. And so you actually need to kind of have a vacation from the vacation as well. You kind of hit on it a little bit on like the types of vacation, like, you know, what you're doing if you're just sitting on the beach or if you're climbing to the top of Kilimanjaro, like maybe these aren't the same. I think another way that vacations are pretty different is kind of like on the length. And so Jason and I talked about this kind of like briefly before we got started, but like for a really short vacation, we were thinking, you know, a couple of days, probably less than a week, then maybe people just sort of hold off
搁置一下。比如有些事情，其实没人会去推进。如果别人有疑问，他们也只会等到你回来再问。你知道，这就是那种短途假期。有时候抽几天时间去玩点有趣的事情、纯粹享受个人时光是很棒的。但从工作的角度来看，这和请一个完整的一到两周的假所起到的作用并不完全一样。因为长假需要别人为你补位，你的工作必须得有人接手。是的，呃，我猜这取决于你工作中的项目推进速度和你的职场状况。但在那种情况下，我觉得这对你的组织也是有用的。另外还有一件事，就像
on things. Like if you had something, you know, no one's going to really work it. If they have a question for you, they're going to just kind of wait till you get back. You know, that sort of like short vacation. And it's good to take those sometimes you can do fun stuff and for just a couple days for yourself personally. But from a work perspective, that doesn't really serve the same sort of role as like taking a full like one to two weeks, then you need people to like fill in for you, your work has to kind of like be taken over yeah uh i guess it depends on the speed of stuff you're going in your your job situation but like at that point too i think that's useful for your organization also there's something just like
杰森刚才谈到的各种休息方式——休息的时长。当你身处一个新地方时，往往需要花上一两天时间，才会真正意识到“明天我不用工作了”。然后，像对我和大多数人来说，假期回去前的最后一天，我基本上是在做心理上的自我调整。所以，如果你只请假1到3天，你是永远无法彻底放松下来的。但一旦你请假达到两周左右，特别是，你知道的，你就有了一个真正抽身并专注于其他事情的好机会。是的。我是说，一旦你开始请假一到两周，那么这个时间段里，那些依赖你的人就绝对无法忍受你完全失联了。我是说，大多数项目都无法停滞两周。所以你需要找一个某种形式的“副手”。对吧。你需要找一个人，在那个特定任务上充当你的二把手，对吧？如果你是团队中数据处理流水线的专家，
jason was talking about the kinds of rest like the length of rest it takes a day or two when you're in a place just to like realize you don't have to do work the next day. And then like, like the day for me, at least like the day before I go back, I'm kind of like prepping myself mentally. So if you're only going on one to three days, you never fully check out. But once you get up to like two weeks, especially, you know, you have a real opportunity to check out and really focus on other things. Yeah. I mean, once you start hitting the one to two weeks, then that's the time when people are just people who depend on you are just not going to tolerate. I mean, most most projects can't be stalled for two weeks. And so you're going to need to find some kind of deputy. Right. Like you're going to need to find somebody who can be your second in command for that particular task, right? If you are the expert on the data processing pipeline for your team, you know, and you're gone for two weeks, like someone else is going to have to be able to fix problems with the data processing pipeline. And so, so, so, you know,
而你离开了两周，那么别人就必须具备修复数据处理流水线问题的能力。所以，所以在你真正能够安心休两周假之前，团队需要具备冗余能力。所以这算是一种，呃，某种程度上的先决条件。否则你根本无法真正去度假。你将不得不在某种程度上保持待命状态。所以，是的，这其实挺不错的。比如，强迫自己休两周假，实际上也是在强迫自己去培训其他人。有些人可能会说，培训其他人只会占用额外的时间，而且对方也并不欠你什么，对吧？但实际上，这会让另一个人去审视这个系统。也许甚至当你回来后，那个人还能继续协助你。这有助于培养你作为工程师的全局观。所以除了能让你喘口气之外，它还有很多积极的好处。
before you can really take a two week vacation, like there needs to be redundancy. So that's sort of a, um, sort of like a prerequisite. Otherwise you're not going to really be able to take a vacation. Um, you're going to have to be on call in some way, shape or form. And so, yeah, it kind of, you know, it's kind of nice. Like, like, like forcing yourself to take a two week vacation is also forcing yourself to train other people. And some people might say, well, training other people just takes extra time and that person is not indebted to it, right? But it's actually, it's going to get another person looking at this system. And maybe even when you get back, that person can continue helping you. It's going to help build your sense of direction as an engineer. So it's got a lot of positives beyond just being able to let you take a break.
如果你足够幸运，能够休假一个月或更久——有时候我们会把这拉长称为学术假（Sabbatical）。那么我认为，你知道的，那就是必须要有一个真正能替代你的人的时候了。这并不是说你将来无法回到那项工作中，而是说你在做的一些目标，将会由其他人来完成。你的组织可能会发生变化，各种事情也可能会变。当你回来时，你真的是离开很久了。我觉得这有一定的价值。虽然我在某家公司工作期间从来没有机会做到这一点，但在两份工作交替的间隙，我确实曾休过三周、四周的假。
And then if you could be so lucky as to be for a month or more, sometimes I guess you stretch that and you call it a sabbatical. Then I think, you know, that's the time when there really has to be a replacement for you. It's not that you are not going to be able to come back to that work, but just there are goals that you were doing, which will be accomplished by other people. There will be changes potentially to your organization, to whatever. And when you come back, you really have been away. And I think there's a certain value. So I've never been able to do this while working at a place. But between jobs, I have taken three weeks off, four weeks off before.
我猜，当时我公司给予的产假足够充裕，当我的其中一个孩子出生时，我能够一次性请大约四周的假。我觉得在那段经历中，你获得了真正意义上的体验，你知道的，我离开了工作，我不仅需要离开工作去干点别的，我还需要弄清楚如何组织我的非工作生活。比如，你知道的，你得让离开工作的时间有点结构，你得找事情做，你得建立非工作的日常作息。我觉得这是对很多事情获得深刻视角的一种非常好的方式。是的，完全是这样。是的。我是说，一旦你离开了一个月，那就不仅仅是维持你的职责了，而是得有其他人来推进这些工作。几乎没有什么事情能停滞一个月而纹丝不动。
I guess when I did my work gave me enough parental leave where I was able to take sort of four weeks off in one go when I had one of my children. And I think there you get a true, you know, I'm away from work, I have to not just be away from work and doing something, I need to figure out like how to organize my non work life. Like, you know, you got to have structure to your time away, you got to have things to do you get our non work routine. And I think that's a really like nice way to get perspective on a lot of stuff. Yeah, Yeah, exactly. Yeah. I mean, once you're gone for a month, then it's not just about maintaining your responsibility, but someone else is going to have to advance them. Almost nothing can just sit still for a month.
所以，是的，你必须被替代。然后，当你离开几个月后回来时，那会是一种非常有趣的感觉，因为你已经“被取代”了。所以当你回来时，问题就变成了：你是要取代那些人，还是去找别的事情做？我是说，这里面有很多问题。当你能休一个非常长的假时，这些最终会是非常、非常具有回报感的假期。而且，我是说，现在我们正处于这样一个阶段，正如我刚才所说，很多人都在用尽他们的带薪休假（PTO），我记不清上限是多少了。我想大概是10周吧，我想。我觉得每个工作场所的规定都不太一样。对。好吧，是的，这绝对是真的。不过我想在我工作的地方，是10周，
And so, yeah, you're going to have to get replaced. And so, yeah. And then when you come back after being gone for several months, then that's a really interesting feeling because you've replaced yourself. And so when you come back, it's like, do you displace those people or do you find something else to do? I mean, there's a lot of questions there. Those are ultimately very, very rewarding vacations when you can take a really long time. And I mean, now we're getting to the point, as I was saying, with so many people maxing out their PTO, and I don't remember what the max is. I think I want to say it is 10 weeks, I think. I think it varies workplace to workplace. Yeah. Well, yeah, that's definitely true. But I think where I work, it's 10 weeks,
也许是10周半左右吧。所以，是的，如果你能——我是说，有很多人确实可以休两周半的假。所以，是的，如果有人这么做了，他们回来后可能会发现团队已经完全变样了。所以，呃，这再次说明，这绝对不是一件坏事。呃，你对此有什么看法？假设你拥有——我是说，产假有点不同，对吧？但假设你有一大笔带薪休假额度。你是会把它拆开，每个月休一周，还是会一次性休个大长假？你会怎么做？哦天哪，这真是个好问题。我是说，我猜这得视情况而定。我觉得我大概不会——我不知道，就我个人而言，不管怎样，
maybe 10 and a half or something like that. And so, and so, yeah, I mean, if you could, I mean, there's people, plenty of people who can take, uh, you know, two and a half months off. And so, yeah, with that, you know, if someone does that, they, they could come back and their team could be totally different. And so, um, which again is, is not a bad thing at all. Um, what is your take on, on that? So let's say you have, I mean, parental leave is a bit different, right? But let's say you have just a huge bank of PTO. Would you break it up and take, you know, a week every month, or would you take a huge chunk of it at once? What would you do? Oh man, that's a great question. I mean, I guess it kind of depends. Like I do not think I would take, I don't know, personally, whatever,
我觉得从财务角度对我来说也一样，反正我就是觉得假期余额为零让我感觉很不舒服。所以我觉得我不会把它全用光，但我肯定会试着去度个假，比如去另一个国家，或者做点什么，或者专注去搞一个我真的很想去做的项目，然后一次性休掉很大一部分假期。我觉得我不会把假期用光到剩零天，我大概会——对我目前的状况来说，我喜欢保留大约一周的可用假期，这样我随时可以再请几天假，而不是变成零天，然后还可以再请几天假。对。所以我喜欢最多把假期用到只剩一周左右，也就是说不想让剩下的假期少于一周。所以，如果我有10周假的话，我会——我要开始畅想如果我有10周假的话会怎么样了。
I guess it's true for like me financially, but as well, it's like, I just don't have like a zero balance doesn't do it for me. So I don't think I would take it all, but I definitely would try to take like a vacation to maybe another country or to something or do some like project that I really wanted to focus on and do and really take a good chunk of it off at one time I don't think I would go down to zero I'd probably go down I like having for my situation I like having you know like a week available so that like I could always take a couple days and then not be at zero and then take a couple days days again. Right. So I like going down to no more than sort of like one week in the like not having less than a week left. So if I had 10 weeks, I'm going to I'm going to fantasize if I had 10 weeks off.
我想这对我来说在经济上确实如此，但同时，就像是，我只是觉得，余额为零对我来说行不通。所以我认为我不会把它们全用光，但我肯定会尝试去另一个国家度假什么的，或者去做一些我真的很想专注去做的项目，并且一次性休掉很大一部分。我想我不会把假期用光到剩零天，我可能会——因为我的情况，我喜欢留出——你知道的，比如留出一周左右的假期，这样我随时可以休几天，然后还不是零，然后再休几天。对吧。所以我喜欢最多只用到剩下一周左右的假期，也就是不想剩下少于一周。所以如果我有10周假，我打算——我来幻想一下如果我有10周假的话。
I think I would take at least a six week chunk and do something amazing. Yeah. Yeah, that makes sense. I think my last big vacation was I did get a month sabbatical through work. And the way it was set up, you had to take the whole month at once. You weren't given an option. And so it was really nice. I mean, we drove cross country, but it definitely was weird coming back. Actually, when I came back, there was a reorg. So when I came back, the organization looked totally different. So this is a bit jarring. But yeah, I'm kind of with you, I think. So actually, one thing to mention is neither one of us have maxed out our PTO. And so number one piece of advice is to not do that and to please take your vacation for all these reasons we talked
我想我至少会抽出一个六周的长假，做一些了不起的事情。对啊。是的，这说得通。我想我上一次长假是通过公司获得了一个月的学术假。它的安排是，你必须一次性休完整整一个月，没有其他选择。所以这真的很棒。我的意思是，我们开车进行了横穿全国的旅行，但回来的时候确实感觉有点怪。事实上，自我回来后，公司进行了一次重组。所以当我回来时，整个组织看起来完全不同。这确实有点让人措手不及。不过是的，我的想法其实跟你差不多。所以实际上，有一点需要提一下，那就是我们两个都没有用完所有的带薪休假（PTO）。因此，第一条建议就是不要那样做，请务必为了我们谈到的所有这些原因去休假
about. But if for some reason I ended up with 10 weeks of PTO, yeah, I would probably take, yeah, probably two months. And yeah, same kind of thing. Just focus or find something cool to do or take an international trip or something. Yeah. Cool. All right. So yeah, folks out there, if you have any vacation tips, we can make it the intro topic of the next show. So give us your feedback on what you think constitutes a good vacation, vacation horror stories, pretty much anything. You can send an email to programmingthrowdown at gmail.com. And we always appreciate reading really cool stories. I got an email just to kind of close this out. I got an email regarding a number of emails,
。但如果由于某种原因我最终积攒了10周的带薪休假，是的，我可能会休假，大概会休两个月吧。是的，也是类似的事情。就是专注于或者找一些酷炫的事情去做，或者来一次国际旅行之类的。好的。酷。所以，是的，听众朋友们，如果你有什么休假小建议，我们可以把它作为下一期节目的开场话题。所以请给我们反馈，告诉我们你认为什么是好假期，假期里的恐怖故事，基本上什么都可以。你可以发送电子邮件至 programmingthrowdown at gmail.com。我们总是很高兴阅读到非常棒的故事。我收到了一封电子邮件，为了给这个话题做个收尾，我收到了一封关于好几封电子邮件的信件，
but one of them regarding our Hash Maps episode that just went live. And someone, there's a really amazing article. I'll have to go back and find it for next week, for next show, about how Google used like brute force to kind of break some, some hashing. So I'll share that to everybody, but I really appreciate that and all the other emails and thanks everyone for
但其中一封是关于我们刚刚发布的“哈希表（Hash Maps）”那一期的。有人发来了一篇非常精彩的文章。我得回去找找，留到下周或下一期节目分享，内容是关于谷歌如何使用类似暴力破解的方法来破解某些哈希算法的。所以我会把这个分享给大家，我真的很感谢那封邮件以及所有其他的邮件，谢谢大家
tuning in. All right. See you next time. music by eric barndollar programming throwdown is distributed under a creative commons attribution share alike 2.0 license you're free to share copy distribute transmit the work to remix adapt the work but you must provide an attribution to Patrick and I, and share alike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
收听。好的，下次见。音乐由 Eric Barndollar 提供，《Programming Throwdown》在知识共享 署名-相同方式共享 2.0 协议下发布。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输该作品，也可以对作品进行重混和改编，但你必须对我和帕特里克进行署名，并以相同方式共享。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。